HEARING ON SENATE EDUCATION WE
HAVESEVENTEEN BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY THERE ARE NO ITEMS
ON CONSENT.
AND DUE TO OUR WERE LENGTHY
AGENDA WILL BE LIMITING
TESTIMONY. TO TWO PEOPLE PER
SIDE WITH TWO MINUTES PER PERSON
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO
WE'RE GOING TO START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE.
AND OUR FIRST AUTHOR IS SENATOR
BELL SENATOR BILL COME ON DOWN.
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
OF IF USER PLEASURE ALL STAR
WITH SP.
ONE FIFTY JUST FINE THANK YOU --
PROUD TO PRESENT SP ONE FIFTY
THIS IS A BILL THAT WILL IMPROVE.
THE ACADEMIC OUTCOMES FOR FOSTER
YOU.
BY EXPANDING THEIR ACCESS TO THE
CHAFEE GRANT -- I'M GOING -- TO
SEE WE GET WITNESSES OF HERE
THEY ARE EARLIER OKAY.
MEASURE DECIDED TO FOR ALL MY
COMMENTS TO SO YOU CAN LISTEN TO
THE WITNESSES.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU AND I'LL
JUST LET EVERYBODY KNOW THAT WE
DO HAVE SUPPORT SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL.
SO WITNESSES YOU HAVE YOU CAN
PICK TWO PEOPLE ARE TWO MINUTES
EACH PLEASE THE PEOPLE THAT
EXPERIENCES TRAFFIC GRANT ISSUE
SO WE'LL.
HAVE THEM AND THEY'RE FOR FORMER
FOSTER VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SENATOR BELL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS DEBBIE RUSHER
AND I AM WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
EXTENSIVE EVIDENCE EXISTS THAT
DEMONSTRATES THAT FOSTER YOUTH
ENTER COLLEGE WITH SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE CHALLENGES AND OTHER
STUDENTS FOSTER YOU HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE TRAUMA OF ABUSE
AND NEGLECT.
HAVE OFTEN BEEN FORCED TO CHANGE
HOMES AND SCHOOLS FREQUENTLY ARE
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
A DISABILITY AND ARE TWICE AS
LIKELY TO TEST BELOW PROFICIENCY
IN MATH AND ENGLISH THAN OTHER
STUDENTS.
ONCE THEY ARRIVE ON A COLLEGE
CAMPUS THEY STRUGGLE TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR BASIC NEEDS A JUST
RELEASED STUDY FOUND THAT A
STAGGERING 43% OF FOSTER YOUTH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS A RATE
MORE THAN DOUBLE THAT OF OTHER
STUDENTS.
AS A RESULT FROSTY'S OFTEN FARE
POORLY IN PARTICULAR DURING
THEIR FIRST YEARS ACCLIMATED
CALLED THE COLLEGE ENVIRONMENT.
A COMMUNITY COLLEGES OVER HALF
OF THE STUDENTS DO NOT ATTAIN A
TWO POINT OH GPA. ONE KEY
COMPONENT TO CALLED SUCCESS IS
ACCESS TO ADEQUATE FINANCIAL AID
THE CHAFEE GRANT PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND
PROVIDES CRITICAL FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. FOR CURRENT FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH ATTENDING COLLEGE
SB ONE FIFTY SIX TO IMPROVE HOW
THIS PROGRAM IS ADMINISTERED. TO
HAVE THE GREATEST POSSIBLE
IMPACT ON FOSTER YOUTH ATTENDING
COLLEGE.
THERE ARE TWO PROVISIONS THE
FIRST WOULD AUTHORIZE C. SACK TO
UPDATE ITS AWARDING PROTOCOLS TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO
RECEIVE FUNDS AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE SCHOOL YEAR WHEN FUNDS
ARE MOST NEEDED.
TYPICALLY THE PROCESS TAKES A
VERY LONG TIME DUE TO THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATIVE PROTOCOL.
RESULTING IN STUDENTS RECEIVING
THEIR AWARDS AT THE END IS THAT
LATE IN THE ACADEMIC YEAR.
I WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO WOULD
AUTHORIZE C. SACK TO AWARD MORE
THAN THE TOTAL ALLOCATION AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
KNOWING THAT STUDENTS WILL
ULTIMATELY NOT CLAIM THEIR
AWARDS SO THAT MORE STUDENTS CAN
RECEIVE FUNDS IN THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR.
THIS PROCESS HAS ALREADY BEEN
USED EFFECTIVELY FOR THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRAHAM.
THE SECOND PROVISION WOULD
PROVIDE SPECIAL CONSIDERATION
FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
WHO DO NOT MEET SATISFACTORY
ACADEMIC PROGRESS STANDARDS IN
THEIR FIRST YEAR?
TYPICALLY STUDENTS WHO DON'T
MEET SAP LOSE ALL FINANCIAL AID
IN THEIR FIRST YEAR AND ONE YEAR
IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH TIME TO
JUDGE OF A FOSTER YOUTH CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE.
GIVEN HOW MANY CHALLENGES THE
STUDENTS FACE IN THEIR FIRST
YEAR.
ONCE ALL FINANCIAL AID IS LOST
THE LIKELIHOOD OF REMAINING AND
ROLL DROPS PRECIPITOUSLY.
UNLIKE MOST STUDENTS THESE ARE
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT HAVE A
FAMILY HOME TO RETURN TO WIN
FINANCIAL AID IS A LOST.
A MORE LIKELY SCENARIO FOR THE
STUDENTS IS HOMELESSNESS AND
DROPPING OUT OF COLLEGE.
ALLOWING THE STUDENTS TO
MAINTAIN THE CHAFEE GRANT FOR AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR WILL PROVIDE A
BRIDGE THAT WILL ENABLE THEM TO
REMAIN ENROLLED IN COLLEGE WELL
THEY WORK TO IMPROVE THEIR
ACADEMIC STANDING.
AND REGAIN ACCESS TO OTHER FORMS
OF FINANCIAL AID.
AND WE HAVE TO US STUDENTS HERE
WHO ARE GOING TO SPEAK ABOUT
THEIR OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
GREAT WE WERE ABOUT THREE
MINUTES INTO YOUR FOUR MINUTES
BUT WILL GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME SENT SENATOR BILL
DEFERRED TEO SO FIRST -- WITNESS
PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME'S
EXIT OVER MOUNTAIN AND I'M HERE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE SP.
ONE FIFTY AND TWO IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM FOR THE FIRST TIME
WHEN I WAS TWO YEARS OLD.
AFTER A FAILED ADOPTION I
REENTERED AT AGE FIFTEEN AND
REMAIN FOSTER CARE UNTIL I AM AS
BETTER AGE. EIGHTEEN ONE FIVE
SECURE DURING THOSE THREE YEARS
I WENT TO FIVE DIFFERENT
PLACEMENT OF FIVE DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS BY FOCUS DURING THOSE --
THOSE YEARS WAS JUST ON
SURVIVING BUT I DID MANAGE TO
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
I KNEW THAT HIGHER EDUCATION WAS
THE KEY TO MY FUTURE AND SO I
WROTE IN COLLEGE OF SAN JOAQUIN
DELTA COLLEGE BUT THE FIRST YEAR
WAS VERY ROUGH.
I DIDN'T HAVE ANY AND ALL
SUPPORT TO HELP ME NAVIGATE THE
PROCESS AND I WAS NEEDING --
NEEDING TO WORK TO SUPPORT
MYSELF.
I STILL HAD THE MENTALITY OF
FOCUSING ON MY IMMEDIATE
SURVIVAL NEEDS WHICH DIDN'T
LEAVE ME MUCH ROOM TO THINK
ABOUT THE FUTURE.
I WAS DOING MY BEST TO MOVE IN --
MOVE MY LIFE FOR IT AND PULL
MYSELF UP BY MY BOOTSTRAPS BUT
THE SUPPORT AND RESOURCES HAT I
NEEDED TO DO.
AND THAT I AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN JUST WEREN'T.
THERE.
AS A RESULT MACINNES DURING THE
FIRST YEAR ONE GRAY AND I DID
NOT MAKE S. A. P..
THIS MEANT THAT I A LOST MY
PHONE MY FINANCIAL AID MY PELL
GRANT MY CAL GRANT MI CHAFEE
GRANT -- LOSE MY FINANCIALLY WAS
A ONE WAY TICKET OUT OF COLLEGE
THERE WAS NO WAY FOR ME TO STAY
AND ROLL WITHOUT FUNDING SO I
DROPPED OUT OF SCHOOL. TWO YEARS
LATER WE DECIDED TO RETURN TO
COLLEGE BUT FOUND THAT I DIDN'T
GET A FINANCE WAY BECAUSE OF MY
PREVIOUS -- SAP DISQUALIFICATION.
I TOOK A TOOK ME EIGHT MONTHS TO
GET ANY FINANCIAL AID BACK AS I
HAD TO GET MY GPA UP.
AT AN ACCEPTABLE LEVEL BEFORE
THE SCHOOL COULD GIVE ME ANY
FINANCIAL AID.
DURING THAT TIME I HAD TO WORK
FOR OLD FULL TIME IN ORDER TO
PAY RENT AND BUY BOOKS WHILE
ALSO TRYING TO GO TO SCHOOL.
ONCE I APPROVED FOR FINANCIAL
AID IT WAS STILL ANOTHER MONTH
BEFORE I WAS ABLE TO ACTUALLY
RECEIVE THE CHAFEE GRAHAM.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT IF I HAD
BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN FNANCIAL
AID I WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
COMPLETE COLLEGE AT A LOT A LOT
SOONER RATE.
TODAY I MEAN U. S. C. --
GRADUATE STUDENTS SEEM TO BE
ALUMNI I'M ALSO A PROUD ADVOCATE
FOR FOX YOUTH.
THOUGH I HAVE OVERCOME THE
PREDETERMINE CITIZENS THAT
SHADOW FOSTER.
MANY FAST YOU STILL STRIVE TO
REACH THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
BUT WHILE FOR ME THE LHASA
FINANCIAL AID BECAUSE AT THE DEL
A DELAY FOR MANY OTHER STUDENTS
THEY ARE NEVER ABLE TO RETURN
INCOMPLETE THEIR COLLEGE
EDUCATION.
THE CHANGES PROPOSED -- CHAFEE
GRANT PROGRAM IN SB ONE FIGHT IT
WILL OPEN UP OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MANY FAST YOU TO TO VANCE AND
EDUCATIONALLOW THEM.
TO SHOW THAT THEY CAN.
TO BEAT THE ODDS AND SO I LIKE
TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SENATE
BILL. ONE FORTY ONE FIFTY THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS.
HI CENTER.
THANK YOU IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
LETTING A SPEAKER TODAY.
SB ONE FIFTY MEANS A LOT TO US
HERE JAY BAY AND I BELIEVE MANY
OTHER FOSTER YOUTH.
I PERSONALLY HAD.
GONE THROUGH.
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AT THE
AGE OF FIFTEEN AND THEN GOT
PLACE TO MANY DIFFERENT TIMES.
AND WENT THROUGH A GROUP HOME
FIRST THAT HAD.
PLACED ME AT A A SCHOOL THAT WAS
MORE CONVENIENT BECAUSE MANY
OTHER GIRLS IN THE GROUP PALMER
GOING THERE.
SO THAT'S KIND OF SET ME BACK A
LITTLE BIT MY EDUCATION
DISCOURAGE ME TO FINISH AND
ABOUT A MONTH BEFORE TURNING
EIGHTEEN MY BIOLOGICAL MOTHER.
SHE HAD -- HAD A DECISION TO
MAKE IN A SEPARATE COURT AND
CRIMINAL COURT WHETHER SHE'S
GOING TO GO DOWN FROM A FELONY
OR PROBATION.
SO I HAD A DECISION TO EITHER
REUNIFY WITH HER NOT AND IT KIND
OF HELPED HER CASE IN CRIMINAL
COURT SO. FOR ME I DECIDED TO
REUNIFY WITH HER -- BECAUSE SHE
IS STILL MY BIOLOGICAL MOM.
HOWEVER IT DID JUST CALL FROM
FIVE ME FROM LIKE AB TWELVE OR
OTHER HOUSING PROGRAMS SO AFTER
I TURNED EIGHTEEN I WAS ELIGIBLE
TO DO THOSE -- AND STAY IN THOSE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS AND I KNEW
WHAT I ATE REUNIFIED WITH HER
THAT I WASN'T GOING TO GET
SUPPORT AFTER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN BUT I MADE THAT
DECISION ANYWAYS AND I STRUGGLED
WITH IT.
AND EVENTUALLY WENT BACK TO
ADULT SCHOOL AND I GOT MY
DIPLOMA AFTER A LONG TIME.
IT WAS NOT EASY.
AND I IT WAS ONLY FIVE CREDITS
AWAY TOO SO IT WASN'T TOO
TEDIOUS AND AFTER THAT I ALSO
ENROLLED IN THE LOCAL JUNIOR
COLLEGE WHICH WAS NOT THE
EASIEST PROCESSED.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE I WAS IN
FOSTER CARE AND FRESNO COUNTY
AND I WAS GOING TO COLLEGE IN
MODESTO SO GETTING THAT APPROVED
AND ALL OF THAT WAS DIFFICULT SO
TO GET MY CHIEF YOU RIGHT AWAY.
AND THAT WOULD HAVE KIND OF HELP
ME AND ALSO BEING HOMELESS WAS
KIND OF A STE.
KIND OF DIFFICULT.
BECAUSE YOU KIND OF FOCUS ON
LIKE WE'RE GOING TO SLEEP AT
NIGHT AND NOT NECESSARILY WE'RE
GOING TO STUDY IN SCHOOL THAT
DAY.
SO FOR ME.
I GOT A JOB AND THEN I GOT A
SECOND JOB AND I DEBATED ON THE
THIRD JOB BUT MY GRADES STARTED
SLIPPING AS I WAS DOING THAT --
HAD I GOT THIS CHIEF YOU GRANT --
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
MORE FINANCIAL SECURITY FOR ME
TO MOVE ON AND KIND OF FOCUS ON
WHAT MATTERS AND LIKE THE BIGGER
PICTURE OF WHERE I WANT TO GO
WITH MY EDUCATION.
AND THAT'S WHY SB ONE FIFTY
ABSOLUTE MEANS THE MOST TO ME
AND I KNOW MANY OTHER YOUTH THAT
WOULD MAKE THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE.
TO I THINK THAT EXTRASUPPORT OF
THE STATE SAYING LIKE I CO AND
WE WERE THERE ONCE. FOR YOUR
JOURNEY IN FOSTER CARE AND WE'RE
STILL HERE.
THANK YOU FOR THE EXCELLENT
TESTIMONY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION AND THEY
CAME OUT I'M SURE MEMBERS TONY
RICE ABOUT THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN LUIS REPRESENTING A SPARE
NOT IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JACKIE ONE WITH
GRAYSON AND TELL POVERTY
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CRISTINA PARKER CALIFORNIA YOU
CONNECTION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
MAYBE IS REPRESENTS SOUNDS A
EVERGREEN COMMON CAUSE HIS
SUPPORT.
DEBORAH BROWN WITH CHILDREN NOW
IN SUPPORT.
RANMA CLEANING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
JUSTIN SELMA COMBAT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCES OFFICE WE DO HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION BUT I TAKE IT
TO THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS IN MAY
WITH A SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION.
TAMMY LYNN FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY
STUDENT AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ENGINE RUNNING THEIR TRAINER
PUBLIC COUNCIL SUPPORT.
OKAY WHEN DEAN ALIGNS FOR BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR AND AS A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH I SUPPORT.
ARE YOU GOOD FOR YOU SEE
STUDENTS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ALEXIS PERRY STUDENT ADVOCATE
AND SUPPORT.
WESLEY SERVER JOHN BURNETT
BECAUSE FEW SPONSOR THE BILL
STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN MIGUEL YOU JUSTICE COALITION
ERIC ACHY CALIFORNIA CONNECTION
AND SPARK INITIATIVE AND STUDENT
NICE SUPPORT.
EMILY ALEXA PNU JUSTICE
COALITION I SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF A
EDUCATION AND OUR BOARD MEMBERS
TOOK A POSITION TO SUPPORT LAST
NIGHT THANK YOU.
ROSARIO THOMAS WITH THE JUST
COLLISION AND A SUPPORT.
MARK FILL PART WITH POLICY
LINCOLN STRONG SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OTHER SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT BEFORE WE GET TO ALL
POSSIBLE OPPOSITION WE ARE GOING --
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
LEYVA HERE LEYVA HERE WILL
PRESENT.
HERE CHIANG RUSSELL.
GRASSO HERE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN
PAN HERE.
VERY GOOD WE HAVE A QUORUM IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
EXCUSE ME WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FIRST ANYBODY FROM
THE COMMITTEE HAVE ANY CUT YES
CENTER WILK.
SENATE BILL THIS AGREE BILL I
HAVE NO IDEA WHY I'M NOT A CO
AUTHOR.
THE WIN -- WHEN APPROPRIATE I
LIKE TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR?
THANK YOU CENTER WILK NO FURTHER%
QUESTIONS SAID ABOUT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE -- I WANT. TO
CLOSE I WANT YOU TO TELL ME WHAT
YOU'RE DOING NOW WITCHER.
COURSE AB I'M VIA A ROSE -- ME --
USCA GRADUATE LIKE OURS STEP BUT
I WAS CURRENTLY -- APPOINTED AS
THE COMMISSIONER OF MY CITY.
SO IT IS DEFINITELY A GREAT
HONOR AS A HAS A FOSTER TO BE
ABLE TO BE IN A PUBLIC POSITION
TO BE ABLE TO ALSO LEAD.
OTHERS.
AND BE A ROLE MODEL FOR THEM.
CONGRATULATIONS YOU WILL BE A
GREAT ASSET TO THE CITY AND AS
YOU SAID AN INSPIRATION TO OTHER
FOSTER YOUTH.
WITH THAT THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY DOCTOR PAN AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IN ONE SB ONE FIFTY THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK WILK I CHIANG
WRESTLE WITH US SO I GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
VERY GOOD WE WILL LEAVE THAT BOB
BILL -- ON CALL FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO COME IN VOTE SENATOR
BILL YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL UP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SENATE BILL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT.
SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND ALL PRESENT THIS
BILL THIS IS -- SB EIGHT OF FIVE
EIGHTY TWO IT'S A CRITICAL
COMPARTMENTS TO PROVIDE EQUITY.
IN TRIAGE GRANTS FUNDS FOR YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND RESTORING THE 40% CUT.
IN TRIAGE GRANTS IN -- TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IN ADDITION THIS BILL
REQUIRES HALF OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH TRIAGE.
FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO DO YOUTH
PROGRAMS BY INCENTIVIZING
COUNTIES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
PARTNER.
CAN INTEGRATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN SCHOOLS.
ACCORDING TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION -- IN
THE FIRST ROUND THE TRIAGE
GRANTS FIFTY APPLICATIONS FOR
PROGRAM FUNDS RECEIPT WERE
RECEIVED.
ONLY SIX OF THESE PROPOSED
PROGRAMS WERE SPECIFIC TO YOU.
SO -- WERE LACKING THAT AND ONLY
THREE OF THOSE MATTER EXCEEDED
THE MINIMUM THRESHOLD FOR
FUNDING SO. THREE OUT OF FIFTY
ACTUALLY -- I'VE GOT FUND.
THEREFORE -- THE GRANTS FOR IF
YOU CENTER PROGRAMS RECEIVE JUST
15% OF THE TOTAL.
AVAILABLE TRIAGE FUNDS.
SINCE THAT TIME WERE YOU CENTRIC
PARTNERSHIPS.
HAVE BEEN PROPOSED TO THE
COMMISSION WERE NOT FUN TO DO
THE THE CUT GRANT DOLLARS.
AND I THINK THIS -- I'LL I'LL
LET -- MY WITNESSES OF TURNOVERS
TOTALLY A WEEK AGO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION
[inaudible]
AND LEVINE CARRILLO ASSOCIATE OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
WILL ALSO WILL SUPPORT THIS.
SENATE BILL WELCOME TO YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES MAKE BETTER
CHAIR MEMBERS TOBY YOU IN WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH COMMISSION
PRITCHETT OPPORTUNITY HERE.
AS THE SENATOR POINTS OUT SOME
YEARS AGO WITHIN THE STATE MADE
AVAILABLE FUNDING TO COUNTY IS
TO INCENTIVIZE IMPROVED WAYS TO
SERVE PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS.
THERE WERE THERE WAS A PRIMARY
EMPHASIS ON SERVING ADULTS
PARTICULARLY ADULTS WHO YOU SEE
EVERY DAY AS HOMELESS ARE
INVOLVED WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT'S AN EXCEPTIONAL PRIORITY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
SO THE COMMISSION HAS TAKEN
STEPS TO BUILD INTO ITS
ADMINISTRATIVE THROUGH ITS
MINISTRY OF RULES REQUIREMENTS
THAT THESE THE FUNDS AT THE
STATE MAKES AVAILABLE AS GRANTS
TO COUNTIES BE DEDICATED HALF TO
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND HAVE TWO
ADULT OR TO PROGRAMS.
AND WITHIN THAT WE DID SPECIFY
THAT THAT A PORTION OF THESE
FUNDS WOULD ONLY BE AVAILABLE
FOR SCHOOL COUNTY PARTNERSHIPS
WE SEE THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO INCENTIVIZE WAYS
THAT SCHOOLS AND COUNTIES CAN
WORK TOGETHER AND HAVE.
AND MANY OF YOU MAY BE AWARE
THAT WE OFTEN FACE CHALLENGES
GETTING INTERGOVERNMENTAL
COOPERATION PARTICULARLY WHEN
JURISDICTIONS DON'T OVERLAP WHEN
THERE'S COMPETITION FOR LIMITED
RESOURCES WHAT THIS BILL IS
REALLY TRYING TO DO WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
THIS ON IS TO SUPPORT THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO SHAPE.
HOW DOLLARS ARE MADE AVAILABLE
IN WAYS THAT CAN INCENTIVIZE
CROSS COUNTY CROSS SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIPS WE'VE HAD SOME
SUCCESS?
LAST YEAR WE HAVE WE'RE FUNDING
FOR SCHOOL COUNTY PARTNERSHIPS
BUT THAT THE DEMAND IS
TREMENDOUS AND SO WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO IS MAKE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AVAILABLE MAKE IT A
LITTLE MORE FLEXIBLE AND ALLOW
THE COMMISSION TO INCENTIVIZE
THE STRONG PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR CHILDREN.
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
AND SUPPORT PARTY MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS YVONNE
CARRY ON WITH THIS SUBSTATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS.
EARLIER THIS WEEK ACCESS HAD
IT'S A LOBBY DAY AND MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS WERE IN THE
CAPITAL SHARING STORIES ABOUT
ISSUES RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH
ARE IMPACTING THE SOCIAL.
EMOTIONAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL WELL
BEING OF THEIR STUDENTS.
THE STORY SUPPORT THE DATA THAT
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING.
RATES OF ANXIETY DEPRESSION
TRAUMA AND SUICIDE IDEATION.
SADLY TOO MANY STUDENTS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS ARE NOT
GETTING THE EARLY INTERVENTION
AND CONTINUED PROFESSIONAL
SUPPORT THEY NEED.
THIS IS IN PART DUE TO A LACK OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO DISTRICTS.
EVEN LAW SCHOOLS ARE OFTEN THE
SAFEST MOST ACCESSIBLE.
AND SITES WHERE STUDENTS CAN
RECEIVE SERVICE THIS SERVICES
DISCREETLY IN FREE OF SIGMA.
BY DIRECTING TRIAGE GRANT
FUNDING TOWARDS YOUTH SB FIVE AT
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT TWO WILL PLACE
A STRONGER FOCUS ON PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION.
SB FIVE A TWO WILL BREAK DOWN
SILOS BY ENCOURAGING INCREASED
COLLABORATION AMONGST A LIAISON
LOCAL PROVIDERS.
ACCESS STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IT
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT IN FUTURE
YEARS.
OUR MEMBERS ARE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SHARON SUCCESS
STORIES.
STORIES ABOUT STUDENTS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS GOT THE
ATTENTION THEY NEEDED AND AS A
RESULT ARE ALIVE HEALTHY AND
DOING WELL.
WE THANK CENTER CENTER BELL FOR
BEING A CONTINUE CHAMPION ON
THIS ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
PLEASE CENTER STERN IF YOU CAN
MOVE OF THANK YOU PERFECT.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
INDICATE RIGHT TO WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
PERSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN SENATE
BILL WHICH I TO CLOSE -- JUST --
TO LET EVERYBODY KNOW AND NOT
SURE DOT SORRY SENATE BILL.
I'M STILL NEW CHERRY FORGET TO
ASK MY COMMITTEE SOMETIMES
COMMITTEE DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO ADD.
THEY DO NOT I GUESS I WAS
READING THEIR MIND SENATOR BILL
PLEASE CLOSE WELL I WAS GOING --
TO AS DOCTOR PAN TO CIRCULATE
THE JAM OF PEDIATRICS MAGAZINE
OF THIS MONTH AND IN THAT
MAGAZINE -- IT DID TALKS ABOUT --
THE DOUBLING.
IN THE LAST DECADE OF OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WAS SUICIDE IDEATION TO
THE EMERGENCY ROOMS IN OUR
HOSPITALS IN THE UNITED STATES
IT WENT FROM. FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND VISITS TO ONE
POINT TWO MILLION VISITS.
AND TEN YEARS.
BOB THIS IS A SERIOUS EPIDEMIC
THAT'S RISING RAPIDLY WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON ALL DIFFERENT AREAS TO
ATTEMPT TO TO DO WITH THIS.
IN THE SCHOOLS IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND ELSEWHERE -- ARJUN AYE VOTE
ON THIS.
THE SENATE BILL.
THE THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
PAN SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NINE SB FIVE EIGHTY TO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA HI LEYVA
AYE WILK.
WILK HI CHAIN WRESTLE WITH US SO
I GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
VERY GOOD WE WILL LEAVE THAT
BILL ON CALL SO THAT OTHER
MEMBERS CAN VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR PELL.
ALRIGHT VERY GOOD I THINK WE HAD
A LITTLE -- NEGOTIATIONS GOING
ON SO
TER
PERCENT AS BEFORE TWENTY EIGHT
ANSWER PORTANTINO YOU'RE GOING
TO JOIN AS WELL.
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO YOUR BILLS
VERY GOOD SIR VANDERVEER READY.
I AM THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO THANK -- THE COMMITTEE STAFF --
FOR WORKING DILIGENTLY BY STAFF
AND THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
AND I A EXCEPT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND STAND THESE
AMENDMENTS DETAIL THE PAGES FIVE
AND SIX WITHIN ALICE'S WILL NOT
ACTUALLY BE CROSSED INTO THE
BILL UNTIL IT.
GOES TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BUT
I AM COMMITTED TO ACCEPTING
THOSE AMENDMENTS.
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA'S A MIX OF IT
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AND
YOU HAVE TO TAKE MY WORD FOR IT
WE JUST HEARD FROM CENTRE BELL
AS WELL.
AND WE HAVE IT PUBLISHED IN
GENERAL PEDIATRICS AND
FORTUNATELY.
SYMPTOMS SUCH FOR CONDITIONS
LIKE DEPRESSION OR THE WHOLE
TIME HIGH FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
ACCORDING TO US DEPARTMENT
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES NEARLY
ONE IN THREE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS SURVEYED
REPORTED FEELING SATTAR HOPELESS
ALMOST EVERY DAY FOR TWO OR MORE
WEEKS IN A ROW.
NEARLY ONE IN FIVE REPORTED THE
DANCE YEARS HE CONSIDERED
ATTEMPTING SUICIDE.
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF ON THE
FRONT LINE OF THESE CRISES AND
SHOULD AND THE SUCH I SHOULD BE
TRAINED TO IDENTIFY AND HELP
STUDENTS WHO ARE SUFFERING.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE SOONER
PEOPLE GET HELP FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
CONCERNS THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE A POSITIVE OUTCOME.
AS AMENDED SB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
WOULD REQUIRE TO CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT EDUCATION TO IDENTIFY
AN EVIDENCE BASED TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO TRAIN CLASSIFIED.
AND CERTIFICATED STAFF ON YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID.
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION CD
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO DISSEMINATE
SELECTED PROGRAM TO ELEAZAR AT
NO COST.
FURTHER ALL ELEAZAR BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WOULD BE CRIER TO
CERTIFY TO THE C. D. E. THAT AT
LEAST 10% OF THE CLASSIFIED AND
10% OF THE CERTIFICATED STAFF.
THAT HAVE DIRECT CONTACT WITH
STUDENTS OR TO CLASSIFIED STAFF
INTO CERTIFICATES STAFF
WHICHEVER IS GREATER HAVE
OBTAINED THE TRAINING.
TRAINING IS NEEDED TO INCREASE
SCHOOL COMMITTEE LEVEL CAPACITY
AND TO IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
ISSUES AMONG USE.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY COALITION
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCATES INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
BORN THIS WAY FOUNDATION AND
CHILDREN NOW I WOULD ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT -- TO BE CLEAR WHAT WE
WANT IS WE WANT THE TEACHERS TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT AT VACATION --
AND MAYBE SOME INITIAL -- WORK
WITH THE CHILDREN BUT WITH THEIR
STUDENTS HOWEVER I AM ALSO VERY
COMMITTED TO BEING SURE THAT WE
ALSO HAVE MORE RESOURCES FOR
ACTUAL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FROM THE HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN
OUR SCHOOL SETTINGS.%
SO I'M VERY PLEASED. TO HAVE MY
JOINT AUTHORS HERE CENTER
PORTANTINO WHO WILL NOW SAY A
FEW WORDS AND THEN WHAT OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR VERY GOOD THANK YOU
CENTER PANTS CENTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YU MADAM CHAIR AT IT
SEEMS LIKE ALMOST EVERY DAY WE
SEE MORE AND MORE DATA -- JUST
RECENTLY OTHER WAS -- SICKENING
ARTICLE ON CNN YESTERDAY ON TEEN
SUICIDE AND LACK OF TRAINED
COUNSELORS -- THE THE
COMBINATION SORT OF A PERFECT
STORM WE HAVE CHILDREN IN NEED
AND WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS TO DEAL
WITH THAT NEED -- RECENTLY IN MY
DISTRICT WE HELD -- TO MENTAL
HEALTH FIRST AID -- WORKSHOPS
WITH OVER THREE HUNDRED PARENTS
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS COME
OUT IN THE POURING RAIN.
IN A COLD DAMP ROOM SPENDING
EIGHT HOURS OF THEIR TIME TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST AID.
THAT TO ME MORE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE SAID THAT THIS IS A CROSS
DEMOGRAPHIC IT'S A CROSS --
SUBURBAN URBAN EVERY SCHOOL
EVERY KID IS FACING THESE ISSUES
AND TO HAVE AN EFFORT TO AND I'M
VERY PLEASED YOU KNOW DOCTOR PAN
AS OUR EYES ARE RESIDENT
PEDIATRICIAN.
IN THE LEGISLATURE -- TO
IDENTIFY THE PROBLEM AND THEN
WORK TO HELP ON THE CAUSES --
YOU KNOW I'M JUST VERY PLEASED
TO JOIN HIM IN THIS EFFORT AND
IT'S A COMBINATION OF TRAINED
PERSONNEL.
RESOURCES -- AND IDENTIFYING THE
NEED WHICH SEEMS TO BE COMING UP
EVERY SINGLE DAY SO -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I THINK THIS IS DEFINITELY
NECESSARY.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO --
NURSES IN PERSON IN SUPPORT
GOING TO USE THIS BUT WHAT THIS
IS I HAVE WITH ME DOCTOR THE
ANDHRA CARP CLARK HARVEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCIES WHO SPEAKING
SUPPORT AND WILL ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS WELL AS
JENNIFER BAYLISS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HERE PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY MORNING WE ARE PLEASED TO
JOIN C. B. H. D. H. CHILDREN NOW
AND LADY GAGA'S BORN THIS WAY
FOUNDATION TO SUPPORT SB.
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT OUR COALITION
CAME TOGETHER IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE WHEN ADULTS HAVE
SHARED LANGUAGE AND RESOURCES
AROUND MENTAL HEALTH WE FEEL
THAT THEY'RE BETTER EQUIPPED TO
HELP YOU THE NEED. TO SIMILAR TO
CPR TRAINING.
BY AN H. OF A IS A SIX HOUR IN
PERSON TRAINING DOESN'T DESIGNED
FOR ANYONE TO LEARN ABOUT MENTAL
ILLNESS IN ADDICTIONS AND IT
ALSO INCLUDES THE RISK FACTORS
AND WARNING SIGNS.
IT'S A LOW COST HIGH IMPACT
TRAINING AND CALIFORNIA WAS
ACTUALLY THE RECIPIENT OF A TWO
YEAR SIMPLY GRANT. TO IMPLEMENT
THIS TRAINING AND SCHOOLS.
SUICIDE IS THE SECOND LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH FOR YOU FIFTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD AND THE
THIRD LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH.
AMONG YOUTH AGE TEN TO FOURTEEN
IT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM AND OUR
COALITION STRONGLY BELIEVES THAT
WE NEED TO BETTER EQUIP TEACHERS
AND SCHOOL STAFF.
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THIS
CRISIS INCREASE ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT FOR ALL ADULT
WHO INTERACT WITH YOU.
THIS TRAINING PROVIDES THE TYPE
OF COMPREHENSIVE Q. MUNITY BASED
APPROACH THAT WE NEED TO FACE
ARE GROWING MEANT USING ALFI
CRISIS IS ME.
ALL OF THE REST OF MY TIME TO
OUR OTHER ONES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
I THANK YOU CHAIR WOMAN LEYVA
VICE CHAIR WELCOME MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER BAYLISS AND
I AM HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT.
SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY EIGHT
BECAUSE ON MAY TWENTY THIRD TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN MY DAUGHTER
ALLISON COMPLETED SUICIDE BY
JUMPING OFF THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE.
SHE WAS ONLY FIFTEEN YEARS OLD.
I BLAME NO ONE FOR MY DAUGHTER'S
DEATH BUT LOOKING BACK I
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TEACHERS
COACHES.
AND FAMILY MEMBERS IN ALLEYS
LIVE TO INTERVENE AND POSSIBLY
SAVE HER WE HAD IF WE HAD TOOLS
LIKE USE MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID
TO HELP US RECOGNIZE THAT SHE
WAS IN CRISIS.
MY EXTREMELY CAPABLE KIND
HEARTED DAUGHTER MIGHT HAVE
GOTTEN THE HELP THAT SHE NEEDED --
ALLEY WAS BEAUTIFUL AND
PERSISTENT GIRL WHO IS GIFTED IN
MATH AND SCIENCE.
SHE'D BEEN AWARDED THIS
SCHOLARSHIP A SCHOLARSHIP AT
MILLS COLLEGE.
SHE WAS THE OLDEST OF FOUR
CHILDREN AND WAS VERY KIND AND
CARING INTERCEPT MEANS -- ALLEY
LOVE MUSIC AND WAS AN
ACCOMPLISHED SWIMMER AND
PARTICIPATED IN LEADESHIP
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS ODYSSEY OF
THE MIND.
HOWEVER ON THE INSIDE ALLEY
STRUGGLED AND WAS VERY GOOD AT
MASKING HER EMOTIONS.
SHE DIDN'T FEEL VALUED OR
ACCEPTED BY OTHERS AND BELIEVED
SHE DIDN'T FIT IN WITH HER PEERS.
THE MORNING OF ALISON SUICIDE --
WAS NORMAL AS ANY OTHER.
KIDS ARE GETTING READY FOR
SCHOOL AND NOTHING SEEMED AMISS
OTHER THAN ALLEY BEING OVERLY
DRESSED FOR A WARM DAY.
BEFORE LEAVING FOR SCHOOL SHE
KISSED HER SIBLINGS AND TOLD
EACH ONE SHE LOVED THEM LOOKING
BACK THIS WAS A LITTLE UNUSUAL.
ALLIE TOLD ME SHE LOVED ME AND
SAID GOODBYE SHE WALKED OUT THE
DOOR.
WE WERE NOT ALLOWED TO WATCH THE
VIDEO FOOTAGE FROM THE BRIDGE
THAT MORNING CONFIRMING ALLEY
HAD JUMPED.
HOWEVER POLICE OFFICER CONFIRMED
THAT SHE LEFT US AT TEN
SEVENTEEN AM.
AFTER I WAS DEBTS WERE GIVEN A
JOURNAL THAT SHE KEPT AS AN
ASSIGNMENT FOR HER TENTH GRADE
ADVANCED ENGLISH CLASS.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I HAD
SEEN THIS JOURNAL AND WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE TWO ENTRIES WITH YOU.
ON DECEMBER THIRTEENTH.
SOMETIMES I THINK ABOUT DYING
OKAY A LOT OF THE TIME BUT I
THINK ABOUT LIFE.
TO HOW MUCH PAIN DO I HAVE TO GO
THROUGH BEFORE I'LL [inaudible]
KING.
BEFORE I CAN LET GO WITHOUT
BEING JUDGED MORE THAN THIS
APPARENTLY.
THE SECOND ENTRIES THE NEXT DAY.
DECEMBER FOURTEENTH FOR
CHRISTMAS I WANT A LIFE I WANT
TO STOP OUT INTO THE SCARS ON MY
BODY I WANT TO NOT BE AFRAID OF
MY PARENTS.
I WANT TO FEEL ACCEPTED I WANT
TO TRUST PEOPLE AGAIN.
I PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE WITH
ADDITIONAL ENTRIES FROM ALLEYS
JOURNAL ALONG WITH COPIES OF MY
TESTIMONY.
THE SIGNS OF CRISIS CAN BE HARD
TO SEE BUT THEY'RE THERE IF YOU
KNOW HOW TO LOOK FOR THEM.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT IF
TRAINING AND USE MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST AID WAS AS COMMON AS
TRAINING FOR FIRST AID.
CPR OR ADMINISTERING AND HAPPY
PAN THEN THE ADULTS AROUND AN
ALLEY WOULD HAVE THE SKILLS AND
TOOLS NEEDED TO INTERVENE.
I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME AND ASK FOR SUPPORT A AND
SENATE BILL.
FOR TWENTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SHARING YOUR VERY MOVING
STORY AND WERE CRITICALLY SORRY
FOR YOUR LOSS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HONEY DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION PROUD TO
BE A CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DEBORAH BROWN WITH CHILDREN OUR
ALSO PLEASED TO BE A CO SPONSOR
THIS MEASURE.
AMY SCOTT EDUCATIONAL
PSYCHOLOGIST THE FOUNDER OF AS
IS NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON SUICIDE PREVENTION
AND EDUCATION. TO RESPOND OR TO
SCHOOL CRISIS HE'S PRIOR TO
SUICIDES I'M IN SUPPORT.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE TOM CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY
IN SUPPORT.
JIMMY ROBIN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
CAROL BECAUSE OF OUR CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA AND SUPPORT.
DANIEL KESSLER BECAUSE ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
SUPPORT.
ALEXIS PERRY SOME WE PARTNER
WITH A PLUS FAMILY SERVICES AND
FULL SUPPORT.
TAMMY LYNN -- PSYCHOLOGY MAJOR
AT SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM WILL
BRING IT UP SORRY ABOUT THAT.
GET TWO SEATS OVER HERE AT THE
END [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS -- I I JUST WANT -- TO
ON RECORD SAY THAT WE HAD A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS WITH THIS
BILL WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS -- WE BELIEVE
THAT MOST OF THOSE CONCERNS ARE
ADDRESSED IN THE ANALYSIS
HOWEVER THERE'S ONE THAT'S NOT
REALLY CLEAR AND THE ANALYSIS
AND THAT IS THE REMOVAL.
OF THIS TRAINING AS A
REQUIREMENT TO OBTAIN A CLEAR
CREDENTIAL AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE -- A
COMMITMENT THAT THAT WILL BE
REMOVED FROM THAT SECTION OF THE
BILL.
I BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A
COMMITMENT ON THE AUTHOR'S PART
TO REMOVE THAT WHEN HE GETS TO
JUDICIARY IS THAT CORRECT TAKING
VI<c.cyan> THAT'S HARDLY A MINUTE</c>
YES OKAY WE'RE TAKING ALL THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE MONEY GOES TO
JUDICIARY TIMING WISE WE HAVE
TODAY. TWO OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ISABEL GARCIA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WITH THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS --
WE'RE GOING TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION WE WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE THE SPONSORS THE
AUTHORS AND EVERYBODY FOR
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS WE THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
ISSUE.
OF FACING ALL OF OUR STUDENTS IN
AND PERSONNEL IT'S PART OF
HAVING -- A SAFE CLIMATE ON OUR
CAMPUS OUR SCHOOL ART COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AS WELL AS K. THROUGH.
TWELVE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SIR ARE IN BETWEEN OPPOSITION.
BETWEEN -- ALSO WENT FROM A HALF
OF THE ANAHEIM UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT -- WE SIMPLY HAD SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL YOU WANT
TO THANK DOCTOR PAN THE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS
THOSE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU ANY
OPPOSITION ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEES
OR ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS.
YES SENATOR ASA [inaudible]
VERY MOVING.
VERY MOVING AN IMPORTANT SUBJECT
AND I JUST WANT THANK YOU.
THANKS.
DOCTOR PAN WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
ITS FOR I JUST WANT FOR SAY I
WHAT I REALLY APPRECIATE -- THE
TEACHERS COMING TO THE TABLE AND
WHEN WORKING WITH US AND ALSO
WITH THAT YOUR COMMITTEE I KNOW
THAT THEY ARE THE EXPERTS AND
EDUCATING OUR CHILDREN AND VERY
VERY MUCH VALUE THEIR INPUT AND
APPRECIATE THAT WERE ABLE TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUES -- AND
CERTAINLY -- WE WANT WE WANT TO
BUILD THIS CAPACITY WITHIN OUR
SCHOOLS BUT ALSO AS I UNDERSTAND
WE NEED TO ALSO IN ADDITION TO
TRAINING OUR TEACHERS ARE
CERTIFICATED AND OUR THE STAFF
AT THE SCHOOL WE NEED TO BE SURE
THAT SCHOOLS ALSO HAVE.
GREATER ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS -- THAT THEY CAN
REFER THEM TO AND CERTAINLY I'M
GOING TO TRY TO WORK ON THAT AS
WELL BEYOND THIS BILL AND EXPECT
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PANNED WE HAVE
A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL.
SO MOVED BY SENATOR WILK MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HIM FOR SB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK WILK I CHIANG LU
ASAL.
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
AND I LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR PAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY
IT'S MUCH APPRECIATED.
ALRIGHT SENATOR PORTANTINO YOU
HAVE THREE BILLS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO START AND GO AND FILE ORDER.
YES VERY GOOD WILL START WITH SB
TWO SEVENTEEN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
SEC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES.
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB.
TWO SEVENTEEN WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
EARLY INTERVENTION GRANT PROGRAM.
THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR EVERY THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLD CHILD.
WHO HAS AN INVITE INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PLAN ALSO KNOWN AS AN
I. E. P.?
BETTER SERVED IN A MARIE
MAINSTREAM EARLY EDUCATION
SETTING.
THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS FOUR YEAR
OLDS WITH AN I. E. P. TO UNROLL
ENTRANT TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN.
ACCORDING TO THE ALEJO
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THOUSAND
CHILDREN AGES THREE AND FOUR
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS HAVING A
DISABILITY.
CURRENTLY IS THE LONG IT IS THE
LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE THE I. E.
P. SERVICES TO THESE THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS WITH DISABILITIES.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY ARE
IN A STATE.
PRIVATE SCHOOL PRESCHOOL OR HEAD
START OR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN ME SAY THAT AGAIN.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR THE I. E. P. WHETHER THE
CHILD IS IN THAT SCHOOL -- THEN
THEY DON'T RECEIVE ANY
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING FOR THE
SERVICES THERE FOR HAVING TO USE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS. TO PROVIDE
THIS NECESSARY SERVICE SB TWO
SEVENTEEN WOULD PROVIDE FUNDING.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO INVEST THE IN THEIR
PROGRAMS AND EXPAND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN.
EARLY INTERVENTION IS CRITICAL
FOR STUDENT SUCCESS CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES WHO RECEIVE
APPROPRIATE SERVICES AT A YOUNG
AGE ARE OFTEN ABLE TO GET HELP
THEY NEED.
AND LEAVE SPEND LEAVE SPEIAL
EDUCATION OR NEED LESS INTENSIVE
SERVICES AS THEY GET OLDER
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT DO ENOUGH TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WHICH DETRIMENTALLY
A FAX.
THIS ALREADY MARGINALIZED GROUP
CALIFORNIA MUST LOOK TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS IN THE MAINSTREAM
QUALITY EDUCATION SETTING.
SO THESE CHILDREN ARE NOT LEFT
BEHIND SO TODAY I HAVE INVEST
SEE FROM THE RIVERSIDE OFFICE OF
EDUCATION'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION AND SANDRA
BY RARE MARRERO.
FROM CSEA TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIR PORTANTINO
WELCOME TO YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AS HE
INTRODUCED ME MY NAME IS INVEST
SEE AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
FOR THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION.
AND IS MY PRIVILEGE TODAY TO
REPRESENT THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS DR
JUDY WHITE.
IN EXPRESSING RIVERSIDE COUNTY
OFFICES OF ITS STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL.
TWO SEVENTEEN INCLUSIVE PROGRAMS
ARE NEAR AND DEAR TO OUR HEARTS
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
BECAUSE THEY ENSURE STUDENTS WHO
HAVE LIMITATIONS BECAUSE OF
THEIR DISABILITIES HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ALONGSIDE
THEIR PEERS.
IT IS ABOUT LEADING ALL KIDS IN
THE CLASSROOM AND THE SOONER
THIS OCCURS THE BETTER.
EVERY CHILDHOOD INCLUSIVE
PROGRAMS EMBODY THE VALUES AND
PRACTICES THAT SUPPORT THE RIGHT
OF EVERY YOUNG CHILD.
REGARDLESS OF ABILITY TO TO PUT
PARTICIPATE IN A BROAD RANGE OF
ACTIVITIES AS FULL MEMBERS OF
THEIR FAMILIES COMMUNITIES AND
SOCIETY. FOR MOST PRACTICAL
STANDPOINT SB TWO SEVENTEEN
WOULD PROVIDE AN ENORMOUS
BENEFITS TO SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE.
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENTS REQUIREMENTS OF ID
A APPLY TO ALL CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES INCLUDING CHILDREN
FROM AGES.
THREE TO FIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE MANDATED TO CREATE THEIR OWN
PROGRAMS ARE CONTRACTS WITH
OTHERS TO OFFER THE SERVICES.
THE EARLY INTERVENTION GRANT%
PROGRAM WOULD ALLOW INCREASE
ACCESS FOR DISTRICTS THAT DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO EITHER HEAD START
OUR STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS.
IT WOULD ALSO SHOW THE LASTING
BENEFITS OF INCLUSIVE PRESCHOOLS
AND THEIR INFLUENCE IN SPREADING
INCLUSIVE PRACTICES INTO THE
LATER GRADES. TO CONCLUDE
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FINANCE IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST CHALLENGES THAT ARE
FACED BY OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
FOCUSING FUNDING ON THESE YOUNG
CHILDREN IS AN INVESTMENT THAT
WILL PAY DIVIDENDS THROUGHOUT
THEIR LIVES.
WE THANK SENATOR PORTANTINO AND
SENATOR ROTH FOR INTRODUCING SB
TWO SEVENTEEN AND URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE I ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CENTER PERERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO SEVENTEEN WE REPRESENT
PARA EDUCATORS THOUGHT SUPPORT.
CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL NEEDS IN
EARLY EDUCATION CLASSROOMS I
WANT TO ECHO SENATOR
PORTANTINO'S COMMENTS AND ADD
THAT OUR MEMBERS WITNESSED.
THE POSITIVE IMPACTS OF QUALITY
EARLY EDUCATION ON THE STUDENTS
THEY SERVE OF THE STUDENTS HAVE
AN EASIER TIME TRANSITIONING
INTO MAINSTREAM CLASSROOMS AND
ARE LESS LIKELY TO NEED
INTERVENTIONS LATER IN THEIR
EDUCATIONAL CAREERS.
ARE SPEC FULLY ASK FOR I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
IN THIS IS IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
THANK YOU ANDREA BALL OUT HERE
ON BEHALF OF THREE GROUPS IN
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DEREK CLINICS ON BEHALF MULTIPLE
CLIENTS INCLUDING THE SIMI
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
FRESNO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION HUMBLE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION SCHOOL EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NICK WRONGLY
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THE YOU
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
CLASS OR AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTIES AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
DISTRICT ADVOCATES ARE BETTER
SCHOOLS ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAROL BECAUSE OF OUR CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
LEE ANGELA READ ON BEHALF OF THE
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION THE PASADENA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PRIVATE SPECIALISTS CALLS ON
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LEILANI I CAN OUT
ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND FRESNO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ADDED THE ABBOTT
CENTER -- CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE ADDED CENTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DEBORAH BROWN WITH CHILDREN NOW
IN SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIANS TRANSPORT. TO ME
FROM YOU KNOW DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
TONY TO CARE ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE JUST WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE WORK THAT THE COMMITTEE THAT
SENATOR STAFF DID IN --
GUARANTEEING THAT THE I. E. P.
WOULD BE THE DETERMINING FACTOR
IN TERMS OF INCLUSION AND WE
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THAT
AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT -- ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR WILK YEAH AND I THIS IS
A GREAT BILLS AS CENTER
PORTANTINO -- FOR ME I HAD ONE
CHILD SPECIAL NEEDS SHE STARTED
GETTING SERVICES AT THREE YEARS
OF AGE WHICH MAIL TREMENDOUS
IMPACT ON OUR LIFE.
SHE WAS A ONE POINT A PAIR
EDUCATOR SHEENA GOING ON GETTING
A BACHELOR'S.
AND NOW SHE'S.
MOSTLY STAY HOME MOM SHE WORKS
PART TIME AS AN SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER WITH A WIN WORKS WITH
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES SELF
THIS S GREAT BILL SO THANK YOU.
IS THERE A MOTION.
YES THANK YOU SEND RESIDENTS.
VERY GOOD THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED CENTER PORTANTINO WHICH I
TO CLOSE YES.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE WHO --
WHO HAS COME OUT?
TO THE EARLY WE INTERVENE AND
THE MORE EFFICIENTLY AT WE
INTERVENE THE BETTER.
THAT CHILD HAS WITH THE
MAINSTREAM -- LIFE -- AND RIGHT
NOW ARE DISTRICTS ARE PAYING FOR
THAT AND WE'RE NOT HELPING THEM
PAY FOR THAT.
AND YOU KNOW THAT'S JUST NOT A
SUSTAINABLE MODEL FOR THE CHILD
OR FOR THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT SENATOR
ROTH IS THE JOINT AUTHOR AND
SENATOR BELL AS A CO AUTHOR.
AND SO AS YOU KNOW -- THEY
DEEPLY CARE ABOUT THIS ISSUE AS
WELL OF WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NOT ABOUT.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
WILL DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING ELSE
OKAY HAS BEEN MOVED BUT CENTER
WELCOME AND SURGERY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ITEM TO SB TWO SEVENTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA LEYVA AYE
WELL HI WILK AYE WHICH CAME TO
WRESTLE.
WITH US SO I GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES WILL
LEAVE ON CALL FOR OUR OTHER
MEMBERS WHEN THEY GET HERE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING ALRIGHT
SENATOR PORTANTINO -- FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU ARE MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING --
PRODUCTIVELY AND COOPERATIVELY
WITH MY STAFF -- TODAY I'M HERE
ALSO REPRESENT SB FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD ADDRESS THE
MOUNTING CRISIS OF MOUNTING
CRISIS OF COLLEGE STUDENTS OF
HOMELESSNESS.
BY ESTABLISHING A HOUSING
RESOURCES WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CSU AND CSU TRANCERS
OFFICE ANDYOU SEE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
REQUIRING CAMPUSES THAT RECEIVE
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT MEASURES TO
MAXIMIZE THE FINANCIAL AID
RECEIVED BY HOMELESS STUDENTS
AND IN SHORT LINKAGES TO
COMMUNITY BASED HOUSING
RESOURCES.
CALIFORNIA'S HAVING A CRISIS IN
HOMELESSNESS AMONGST ITS COLLEGE
STUDENTS ACCORDING TO A
200-018-2000 NINETEEN REPORT BY
THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANTERS
OFFICE OF FULL ONE IN FIVE
STUDENTS HAS EXPERIENCED AN
EPISODE OF HOMELESSNESS WITHIN
THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS A STUDY
OF CALIFORNIA STATE.
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS FOUND THAT
11% OF STUDENTS REPORT BEING
HOMELESS ONE OR MORE TIMES IN
THE LAST YEAR AND 5% OF
CALIFORNIA YOU SEE STUDENTS ALSO
REPORT.
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS SO THIS
IS AFFECTING ALL OF OUR SEGMENTS
AND FRANKLY ALL OF OUR CHILDREN
NOT SURPRISINGLY HOMELESSNESS
SERIOUSLY AFFECTS OUR STUDENTS
ABILITY TO REMAIN IN SCHOOL AND
BE SUCCESSFUL WHAT WE WANT WE
WANT OUR KIDS IN CLASS.
SUCCEEDING THIS ISSUE OF STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS IS PARTICULARLY
ACUTE AMONG STUDENTS OF TENDING
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OR DORM ACCESS IS LIMITED.
OF THE HUNDRED FIFTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN CALIFORNIA ONLY
ELEVEN HAVE DORMS SB FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT WILL AUTHORIZE COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES. TO COLLABORATE
WITH LOCAL HOMELESS SERVICE
AGENCIES TO IMPLEMENT A COLLEGE
FOCUSED RAPID RE HOUSING PROGRAM
THESE PROGRAMS WOULD PROVIDE
HOUSING IDENTIFICATION RENTAL
ASSISTANCE IN INTENSIVE CARE
MANAGEMENT. TO QUICKLY MOVE
STUDENTS FROM HOMELESSNESS INTO
HOUSING COUPLED WITH MEANINGFUL
SUSTAIN CONNECTIONS TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
COLLEGES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
ESTABLISH A RELATIONSHIP WITH
OUR LOCAL HOMELESS CONTINUUM OF
CARE AND DEVELOP A REFERRAL
MECHANISM INTO THEIR COUNTIES
COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEMS. FOR
HOMELESS SERVICES AND TRAIN
STAFF REGARDING ON HOW TO ACCESS --
HOUSING ASSISTANCE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD ALSO BE
REQUIRED TO REVIEW THE FINANCIAL
AID PACKAGES OF ALL STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING IN THE HOUSING
PROGRAM INSURE THAT HOMELESS
STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING AID.
IN A TIMELY MANNER AND ADOPT
POLICIES THAT ENABLE HOMELESS
YOUTH TO MAINTAIN ACCESS TO
pBIGGEST FRUSTRATIONS IN THE
WHOLE SYSTEM.
STUDENTS LEAVE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF AID THAT'S AVAILABLE
ON THE TABLE BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
COLLECTING CONNECTING THEM TO
THAT EIGHT AND I KNOW THE CHAIR
SHARES THAT -- ISSUE AS WELL
EACH CAMPUS THAT RECEIVES
FINDING WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT AN ANNUAL REPORT WHICH
WOULD BE COMPILED AND SUBMITTED
TO THE LEGISLATURE DETAILING HOW
MANY STUDENTS RECEIVE SUPPORT.
THE DURATION OF SUPPORT AND THE
RETENTION AND GRADUATION RATES
OF THE PROGRAM SO WE HAVE BUILT
IN ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS ACTUALLY.
HAVING A POSITIVE EFFECT THIS
BILL IS -- CALL AGAIN JOINTLY
AUTHORED BY SENATOR ROTH AND
PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL -- TODAY I HAVE
HERE WITH ME -- DEBBIE ROUTE
YOUR FROM THE JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH AND ALEXIS
BARRIERS A CURRENT STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE AND SO I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY [inaudible]
HONORING.
A BOOK THAT.
YEAH OKAY -- SO ONCE AGAIN I AND
EVERY RUSSIA JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR US CONSIDERING THIS
BILL.
WE KNOW THAT IN TODAY'S ECONOMY
A POST SECONDARY CREDENTIAL IS
MORE ESSENTIAL THAN EVER BEFORE
AND YET THE COLLEGE COMPLETION
GAP BETWEEN LOWEST THE LOWEST
INCOME STUDENTS AND THE HIGHEST
INCOME STUDENTS HAS GROWN BY 24%
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS.
WHILE 60% OF WEALTHY STUDENTS
COMPLETED AGREED JUST 11% OF
POOR STUDENTS.
TO CONTRIBUTING TO THIS
DISPARITY IS THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA IS HAVING A CRISIS IN
HOMELESSNESS AMONG ITS COLLEGE
STUDENTS FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHOSE ACADEMIC PROSPECTS ARE
ALREADY PRECARIOUS.
THE EXPERIENCE OF HOMELESSNESS
IS EXTREMELY DISPLEASED
STABILIZING AND MAKES CALLS
COMPLETE COMPLETION PROFOUNDLY
UNLIKELY.
STUDENTS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE A KEY
CROSSROADS IN THEIR LIFE PATH BY
PROVIDING INTERVENTIONS TARGETED
TO THE HOMELESS STUDENTS-SUBPOPULATION.
THESE INDIVIDUALS CAN BE
SUPPORTED TO MOVE TOWARD SELF
SUFFICIENCY ECONOMIC
INDEPENDENCE AND LIFE
SATISFACTION.
BY DOING NOTHING WE INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THE STUDENTS
WILL INSTEAD ENTER THE RANKS OF
THE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS.
AN OUTCOME THAT IS NOT ONLY
DETRIMENTAL TO THE INDIVIDUAL
BUT COSTLY TO SOCIETY AS A WHOLE.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE POLICIES AND
PRACTICES IN HIGHER EDUCATION
DESIGNED TO HELP RETAIN LOW
INCOME STUDENTS THERE ARE
VIRTUALLY NO PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY FOR STUDENTS TO
HELP THEM REGAIN HOUSING
STABILITY.
THOSE THAT DO EXIST TEND TO
OFFER ONLY VERY SHORT TERM
EMERGENCY HOUSING OPTIONS RATHER
THAN LONG TERM SOLUTIONS.
THE MODEL PROPOSED BY S..
BY SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT IS BASED
ON A PROVEN FORM OF HOUSING
INTERVENTION KNOWN AS RAPIDLY
HOUSING AND WILL LEVERAGE THE
EXPERTISE BUILT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING PROVIDERS.
OVER THE LAST DECADE TO QUICKLY
AND EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS.
THE STRATEGIES PROPOSED BY SB
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT OFFER REAL
SOLUTIONS USING PROVEN TACTICS
THAT WILL ENABLE THIS
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE SUBSET
OF THE STUDENT POPULATION. TO
NOT ONLY X. AND HOMELESSNESS BUT
REMAIN ENROLLED IN COLLEGE TO
COMPLETE THEIR DESIRED
CREDENTIAL AND GO ON TO BE
PRODUCTIVE CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY HIRED YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
I CAN MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ALEXIS BERRIES AND I'M A CURRENT
STUDENT I'M HERE TO SHARE ABOUT
MY OWN EXPERIENCE BEING HOMELESS
DURING THE TIME -- DURING MY
TIME AS A COLLEGE STUDENT AND
WHY I THINK THE PASSAGE OF FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT IS SO IMPORTANT.
I SPENT EIGHTEEN YEARS IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AS A RESULT
OF BOTH OF MY PARENTS BEING
INCARCERATED AND FACING LIFE
SENTENCES.
MY EARLY YEARS WERE CHALLENGING
I WAS CONSTANTLY BEING TOLD
YOU'RE GONNA END UP IN PRISON OR
DEAD JUST LIKE YOUR PARENTS.
FOSTER CARE FOR ME WAS A NUMBER
OF FELT PLACEMENTS HAVING TO
PACK MY BELONGINGS IN A BLACK
TRASH BAG THEY MOVED TO ANOTHER
PLACE OFTENTIMES SEVERAL
COUNTIES AWAY.
EACH TIME I MOVED I WAS FORCED
TO CHANGE SCHOOLS WHICH LEFT ME
FAR BEHIND ACADEMICALLY.
NONE THE LESS I LOVE SCHOOL
ALTHOUGH NOT FOR THE REASON MOST
IT. FOR ME SCHOOL WASN'T OUTLET
TO ESCAPE THE PHYSICAL ABUSE
THAT I ADORED BY THOSE WHOSE JOB
IT WAS TO PROTECT ME.
AS I APPROACH HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION I WANTED TO GO TO
COLLEGE MORE THAN ANYTHING IN
THE WORLD TO BE ABLE TO PROVE TO
MYSELF THAT I COULD DO IT.
BY THE GRACE OF GOD I WAS ABLE
TO COMPLETE HIGH SCHOOL AT THE
AGE OF SEVENTEEN AND FILL MY
DREAM OF BECOMING A COLLEGE
STUDENT.
THAT DREAM HOWEVER.
THE DREAM HOWEVER AGAINST
REALITY IT WAS AGAINST REALITY
WHEN I TURNED EIGHTEEN I FOUND
MYSELF WITH NO PLACE TO LIVE.
AS AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD WITH NO
SAVINGS NO CREDIT HISTORY AND NO
ADULT SUPPORT FOR ME TO FIND
HOUSING I FOUND MYSELF HOMELESS.
I SPENT THREE MONTHS SLEEPING IN
MY CAR WHILE ALSO TRYING TO STAY
ENROLLED IN COLLEGE FINDING
PERMANENT HOUSING AND WORKING
FULL TIME AT PETE'S COFFEE AND
TEA AND FARMERS INSURANCE.
BEING HOMELESS WAS EXTREMELY
STRESSFUL AND SCARY I WANTED TO
FIND A SAFE NEIGHBORHOOD TO PARK
MY CAR OVERNIGHT BUT THAT MEANT
HAVING TO CONSTANTLY MOVE MY CAR
TO AVOID BEING HARASSED BY
POLICE.
I WOULD SHOWER IN THE BATHROOM
AT WORK AND I DON'T TELL ANYONE
THAT I WAS HOMELESS BECAUSE OF
THE NEGATIVE THE NEGATIVE STIGMA
AND THE CONCERN OF ME LOSING MY
JOB.
THROW ALL THIS I WAS ATTENDING
SANTA ROSA JUNIOR COLLEGE WHEN I
FIRST ATTENDED COLLEGE I WAS
HOUSE TO THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
AND I DID WELL.
BUT WHEN I BECAME HOMELESS I
STARTED TO FEEL MY CLASSES.
MY TIME HOMELESS ENDED UP
SENDING ME BACK YEARS.
AT AND I LOST ALL MY FINANCIAL
AID BECAUSE OF MY POOR GPA WHICH
THEN FURTHER DELAY MY ABILITY TO
GET BACK ON TRACK WITH MY
STUDIES.
I THINK I WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO STAY ON TRACK WITH MY COLLEGE
COURSES AND I WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO BE FURTHER ALONG AT THIS
POINT IN MY EDUCATIONAL CAREER
THAN I AM NOW.
I WAS FORTUNATE THAT I WAS A
RESOURCEFUL PERSON AND I SAVE
MONEY FOR MY WORK DURING THE
TIME THAT LIVED IN MY CAR --
EVENTUALLY I FOUND A I FOUND A
LANDLORD WHO WAS SYMPATHETIC TO
MY SITUATION AND WAS GOING TO
WRITE WITH ME.
I'M KNOWN ROLES IN THE PAST WITH
A LAW PROGRAM AT SAN JOAQUIN
DELTA COLLEGE BUT NOW BUT MANY
OTHERS ARE NOT AS FORTUNATE AS I
AM.
AND THEY HAVE TO GIVE UP ON
THEIR STUDIES ENTIRELY FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT WILL HELP MANY OF
THESE STUDENTS TO STAY ON TRACK
AND NOT SUFFER THE KIND OF
CHALLENGES THAT I FACE.
SO WITH THAT I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I'M
GONNA ASK THE AUDIENCE TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF FOLKS THAT ARE
TESTIFYING.
IF YOU WANT HAVE A CONVERSATION
IF YOU'D STEP OUTSIDE THAT WOULD
BE GREAT TO LITTLE OUT OF HERE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME
AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE HI MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH MORE AND I'M A
CURRENT STUDENT VIEW COLLEGE AND
I AM IN FAVOR OF THIS -- I
MYSELF WAS HOMES FOR OVER FIVE
YEARS AND THE SECOND TIME I
BECAME ALMOST ACTUALLY HAD TO
DROP OUT OF COLLEGE.
SO WHEN I GOT STABLE AGAIN I
WENT BACK IN COLLEGE I'M
ACTUALLY ALMOST BECAME ALMOST
AGAIN.
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
RUNNING OUR HOUSE PUT UP FOR
SALE.
SO I AM REALLY IN FAVOR OF THIS
FOR A LONG PEOPLE TO MAINTAIN
STABILITY AND BE ABLE TO FINISH
GOING TO BE ABLE TO IMPROVE
THEIR LIVES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT IF YOU TO STATE YOUR
NAME IN OPPOSITION ARE YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE.
I'M CHARLES STEVENS AND I AM A
STUDENT IN BI<c.cyan> COLLEGE I</c>
BRIEFLY EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
AFTER THE CAMPFIRE.
IN PARADISE AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT GOOD MORNING
EIGHTY AGUILAR FARM BE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE I'M A STUDENT SUPPORT
SPECIALISTS AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT MY NAME IS MY
SEE BAILEY I'M A BUTTE COLLEGE
SOON AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF
SB.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT HELLO I'M
SUPPORT
USE -- I EXPERIENCED THE LOVE.
BACKSLASH AND AWAY FROM BEING A
FOSTER HOME AND THEN.
AS SOON AS I GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL I HAD NOWHERE TO GO.
AND HIS FAMILY AND FRIEND WAS
THERE FOR ME.
AND I FEEL LIKE THIS BILL WILL --
BE APPRECIATED BUT A LT OF BOTH
FUNDS TO YOU ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GEORGE SOCKET I AM A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND I'M A
COLLEGE STUDENT AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT THE SPELL.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THIS IS ONE
OF OUR LOBBY DAY BILLS AND WARY
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT.
PRIME MACLAINE YOU THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
BERNIE REINERTSEN BOARD TRUSTEE
SAN DIEGO.
TAMMY LYNN OF FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND I HAD EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS I'M A SOCK STATE
STUDENT AND I FULLY SUPPORT.
ARE YOU GOOD FOR YOU SEE
STUDENTS ASSOCIATION AND UC
DAVIS STUDENT IN FULL SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING PARTIAL OFFICE
RALLY WITH THE UC SINICIZATION
WE'RE PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR
AND STRONG SUPPORTER THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ADAM HARVEY UC
DAVIS STUDENT ASSOCIATION -- IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JACKIE ONE WITH
GRAYSON AND SHALL POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING QUE WHEN DEAN WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AND POLICY LINK IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
SORRY IT'S ALMOST WITH THE
JUSTICE COALITION ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
CAN GO YOU JUSTICE COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT.
TONY RICE REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT.
MY HOW THE MARCOS SACRAMENTO
STATE UNIVERSITY STUDENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERG WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION WE
WERE A LITTLE LATER LETTER BUT
WE'RE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SIMILAR LACKS UP IN YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION KNOWS KICKED
OUT OF COLLEGES USE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MERRY WASHINGTON WITH CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL.
DEBORAH BROWN WITH CHILDREN NOW
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR OF MANY
TIAS SOMEWHERE IN TWO TO HAS
TODAY I'M HERE.
TO REPRESENT SOUNDS THE
EVERGREEN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
AND ALSO YOUR AS A FORMER MEMBER
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN CITY
COUNCIL FROM SAN JOSE.
VERY MUCH SUPPORT IN SAN JOSE
THIS IS THE WE'RE WE'RE HAVING A
HOUSES AND CARS LIKE EVERYWHERE
ELSE BUT WE NOW HAVE DUTIES ARE
BEING ONE OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE
HOUSING REGIONS IN THE NATION.
IS THE WHOLE ON A STUDENT AT
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE IN A
PRODUCT BECAUSE IT J. BAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ERICA ACHY FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
UC DAVIS STUDENT AND YOUTH
ADVOCATE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AGES
FOURTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR HOMELESS
FOSTER IN JUVENILE YOUTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CRISTINA PARKER WE CALIFORNIA
CONNECTION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
CHAPTER NAME IS FROM THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
AND SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF OF JOHN BURKE IN THE
ADVOCATES FOR YEARS FALLEN
FAMILY IN U. S. C. I'M A STRONG
SUPPORT.
WESLEY SAVER CHAMBER NEVER GETS
VIEWED CO SPONSOR STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LIANE TO READ ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGE ADMISSION
COUNSELING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW ON BEHALF OF THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
JUSTIN SELLING CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICABLE JUST CHANCES OFFICE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
BUT TAKING INTO OR BOARD IN MAY
WITH THE SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU -- ANY MEMBERS OF
OPPOSITION HERE.
SEEING NONE.
I'M GONNA PULL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
CAN I HAVE A MOTION.
MOTIONS BEEN MOVED CENTER PLEASE
CLOSE THANK YOU I FIRST OF ALL
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
STUDENTS AND ACTIVISTS SEN.
FOSTER YOUTH AND EVERYONE WHO'S
COME OUT HERE.
TO YOU KNOW SHARE THEIR PERSONAL
STORY AND HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL AND ALL OF THE
SPONSORS AND FOLKS HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE -- LONG
BEFORE THIS BILL WAS INTRODUCED --
JUST EMPHASIZES HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS AND HOW A SEARS THE NEED IS
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ITEM SEVEN SB FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA WILK HI
WILK I CHIANG WHO WRESTLE.
WITH US SO I GLAZER MCGUIRE CAN.
THOSE TWO ZERO SO YOU'RE OFF TO
A FAST START AND WE WILL HOLD
THAT OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
[inaudible]
AND MEMBER [inaudible]
THE RECOMMENDATION.
OKAY UP NEXT IS GOING TO BE ITEM
FIFTEEN SB SEVEN TO NINE WITH
THE RECOMMENDATION TO PASS AND
SEND TO A PROBES SO SEN SENATOR
FORTINO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU -- MISTER VICE CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES -- TODAY I AM
PRESENTING SB -- SEVEN TWENTY
NINE EXISTING LOST OUT WHICH IS
A PUBLIC SCHOOL FINANCING SYSTEM
THAT REQUIRES STATE FUNDING FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO BE CALCULATED
PURSUANT.
TO THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA LC FF AS IT IS COMMONLY
CALLED.
EXISTING LAW SPECIFIES THE
AMOUNT OF THE BASS GRANT -- IN
THE 200-013-2000 FOURTEEN YEAR
AS PROVIDED AND REQUIRES THAT
AMOUNT TO BE INCREASED BY A
SPECIFIC SPECIFIED COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT IN SUBSEQUENT
YEARS.
NOT WITHSTANDING THE SPECIFIED
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT SB
SEVEN TWENTY NINE WOULD REQUIRE
THE AMOUNT OF THE BASS GRANT FOR
THE 200-019-2000 TWENTY FISCAL
YEAR. TO BE INCREASED BY A FIVE
POINT ONE SIX COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT.
THE TOTAL IN THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA WAS IMPLEMENTED --
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN PLACING
FUNDING DECISIONS IN THE HANDS
OF LOCAL DISTRICTS SO THAT THEY
COULD MORE ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED
NEEDS ON THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THE LC AFFECT PROVIDES DIRECTION
FOR LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
ALLEY ETS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO SPEND THEIR
STATE FUNDING.
THE FUNDING STRUCTURE OF LCF IS
DIVIDED INTO BASS SUPPLEMENTAL
AND CONCENTRATION GRANTS
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS ARE DESIGNED
FOR ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
FOST YOU THEN STUDENTS THAT COME
FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE LONG
STRESSED THAT THE BASE FUNDING
LEVEL IN THE LCI PFAFF WAS SET
TO LOW FROM THE OUTSET AND I
AGREE.
STRONGLY WITH THAT.
OPINION THIS PROPOSAL IS AN
ATTEMPT TO INCREASE THE BASE
FUNDING LEVEL FOR THIS FISCAL
YEAR AND BECOME PART OF A
PERMANENT PART OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA MOVING FORWARD.
THE FUNDING WILL HELP LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH COST
PRESSURES -- AND EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES THAT ARE FACING RISING
OPTIONAL COSTS -- AND ALSO FIXED
COSTS RETIREMENT COSTS
HEALTHCARE AND AS WE'VE HEARD
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
FRANKLY I DON'T THINK ANYONE
ARGUED WITH THE IDEA OF TRYING
TO CREATE MORE OF A LOCAL
FUNDING FORMULA.
AND I DON'T THINK ANYBODY ARGUED
WITH CREATING A PROGRAM THAT
GAVE MORE FUNDS TO DISTRICTS
THAT HAD CERTAIN NEEDS WHERE THE
ARGUMENT CAME IS THE BASE
FUNDING WAS SET. TO LOW EVEN
TODAY WHEN WE CELEBRATE FULL
FUNDING OF LCF PFAFF.
WHEN YOU ADJUST FOR INFLATION OR
NOT AT TWO THOUSAND SEVENS
FUNDING LEVEL SO LET ME SAY THAT
AGAIN WERE CLAIMING VICTORY WHEN-IT'S A HALF FACTORY YOU KNOW I'M
PROUD THAT WE'VE INCREASED
FUNDING?
BUT THE BASE WAS JUST SET TO LOW
AND DISTRICTS AROUND THE STATE
ARE FACING THAT CRUNCH IN
DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND IN DIFFERENT MANNERS BUT
MANY OF THEM IF NOT ALL OF THEM
NEED AN INCREASE FUNDING LEVEL
AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
EDUCATION FUNDING WE TALK ABOUT
OUR KIDS EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
ALWAYS STARTS WITH IT'S A
PRIORITY WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS GENERATION HAS THE
TOOLS TO SUCCEED WE HAVE TO
FOCUS ON EDUCATION.
BUT IT WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
PRIORITIZING.
WE DON'T OFTEN FOLLOW THROUGH ON
THAT SO THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO DO
A MINOR ADJUSTMENT THAT WOULD
HAVE A BIG IMPACT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE WE WERE
APPRECIATIVE OF GOVERNOR BROWN'S --
QUICK MOVEMENT TO FULLY FUND THE
LC A FAST BUT JUST TO CENTER
PORTANTINO STATED IT IS IN NO
WAY ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS
OUR SCHOOLS ARE IN DESPERATE
NEED OF HAVING ADEQUATE FUNDS TO
MEET THE MULTITUDE OF NEEDS --
THAT OUR CHILDREN HAVE TO BRING
THEM INTO THE NEXT COMPETITIVE
CENTURY SO WE DO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT MOVING AS FOR THANK YOU.
CAROL BECAUSE OF OUR CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
BOTH OF YOU SAID.
RON RAPPER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
IN THE GARAGE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND ALL I MY COMMENTS WITH THE
PRIOR SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
HIGHLAND ON BEHALF OF THE ABBOTT
CENTER OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND FRESNO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH AT CHAU
IN SUPPORT.
GREAT THANK YOU.
THE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION.
I I I I ON SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS
WHY WE'RE DOING IT THIS WAY AS
OPPOSED TO DOING IN A TRAILER
BILL.
WE HAVE IT THERE'S ALSO GOING TO
BE A BUDGET REQUEST AS WELL. TO
SO WE'RE HEADING IN ON BOTH
SIDES OKAY IS THAT YOUR CLOTHES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TO INCREASE SCHOOL FUNDING.
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
CLERK.
ITEM FIFTEEN SB SEVEN TWENTY
NINE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA WILK HI
WILK I CHIANG LASSELL. TO
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE HAND.
BEGIN TWO ZERO OFF TO QUICK
START LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER.
THEN SEE SITTING THERE SO THIS
IS ITEM THREE SB.
FOUR NINETEEN WITH THE RIVER
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION OF DO
PASSED TO THE FLOOR -- WONDERFUL
SO CENTER SKINNER WHENEVER.
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE CERTAINLY SB
FOUR NINETEEN I THANK YOU OF A
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS SAYS
BEFORE NINETEEN WILL -- IT WILL
IS BRINGING BACK WE HAVE
SUPPORTED THIS BILL IN THE PAST --
IN OUR PREVIOUS A MEASURE --
THIS WOULD ELIMINATE WILL FOLD
DEFIANT SUSPENSIONS FOR OUR
FOURTH THROUGH EIGHTH GRADE
STUDENTS.
AND EIGHT EIGHT CAST THE WILL
FOR THE ELIMINATION OF WILLFUL.
DEFIANT SUSPENSIONS FOR OUR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS BECAUSE THAT
PORTION HAS A SUNSET IN --
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SUPPORTED THESE
EFFORTS TO ELIMINATE THIS VERY.
SUBJECTIVE CATEGORY OF
SUSPENSIONS IN THE PAST WITH
THAT ALLOW ME WITNESSES TO SPEAK
[inaudible]
THE MORNING.
SHARE MEMBERS WITH MANY.
YES GOOD MORNING AGAIN.
MY NAME IS ANGELINA TURNER AND
I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY OP PUBLIC
COUNCIL IN A PROUD BECAUSE
SPONSOR OF US BEFORE.
NINETEEN BEGIN TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF US BEFORE.
NINETEEN WILSON CREW STUDENT
OUTCOMES ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO
ADOPT ALTERNATIVE SUSPENSIONS
AND EXPULSIONS.
THROUGH SUBJECT TO SUSPENSIONS
AND EXPULSIONS ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY THAN THEIR PEERS NOT TO
FINISH HIGH SCHOOL OR TO HAVE
CONTACT WITH THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION CODE
SECTION FORTY EIGHT NINE HUNDRED
K..
IS A VERY BROAD AND HIGHLY
SUBJECTIVE CATCH ALL CATEGORY
COVERING A WIDE RANGE OF LESS
SERIOUSNESS BEHAVIOR.
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE NOT PAYING
ATTENTION FAILING TO DO HOMEWORK
TALKING BACK AND CHEWING GUM.
DESPITE REFORMS AND THE
ELIMINATION OF THIS CATEGORY OF
SUSPENSION FOR KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH THIRD GRADE.
DISPARITIES PERSISTENCE SCHOOL
DISCIPLINE ACROSS THE STATE.
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THE
DISPARITIES IN DISCIPLINE FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR ARE DUE IN
PART TO BOTH CONSCIOUS AN
INTENTIONAL DISCRIMINATION.
AND BROAD SUBJECTIVE DISCUSSIONS
SUCH THAT WE HAVE ON THE FORTY
NINE HUNDRED K..
IS PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT BIAS.
STATE LEVEL DATA REVEALED THAT
BLACK STUDENTS IN 200-017-2000
EIGHTEEN WERE LESS THAN 6% OF
THE A ROLL MEANT FOR THE STATE
BUT NEARLY 16%.
OF DEFIANCE INSTRUCTION
SUSPENSIONS FOR THAT SCHOOL YEAR.
THOROUGHLY STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WERE 13% OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENT ROLE MEANT.
GET THE COMPRISES 31% OF
DESTRUCTION DEFINED SUSPENSIONS.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD CONTINUE TO
LEAD ADDRESSING THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE.
AND SCHOOL DISCIPLINE
DISPARITIES IN RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE HI.
SB [inaudible]
FOR NINETEEN THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED HELLO MY NAME IS
JADE I'M A CAR I AM A SENIOR A
SECOND MUCH HER HIGH SCHOOL. 70%
OF THE STUDENTS IN MY HIGH SCORE
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
AND WE HAVE THE HIGHEST RATE OF
SUSPENSIONS FOR WELL FOR
DEFIANCE IMPACTING AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS IN ACCOUNTING
[inaudible]
I I'VE BEEN A STUDENT OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS FOR MOST OF MY
EDUCATIONAL LIFE THAT BEING SAID
NOW I AM GOING TO SHARE MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES.
THAT HAPPENED THIS YEAR.
IN THE MORNING TIME AROUND SEVEN
THIRTY I WAS WALKING TO GET
BREAKFAST BEFORE THE BELL RUNG.
AS I WALKED IN I HAD A PAIR OF
APPROVED BLACK SWEAT PANTS.
THEN THE DEAN ACCESS TO ME IF MY
SWEATPANTS FOR UNIFORM APPROVED.
I SAID YES AFTER THE PROTEST
THAT WE HAD HAD WE ARE NOW ABLE
TO WEAR BLACK PANTS.
HE SAID THAT IT HAS TO BE JEANS
NOT SWEAT PANTS.
I THIRTY FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT MY FIRST
ENCOUNTER WITH JUSTINE.
SO I ASKED TO SPEAK TO MY
COUNSELOR.
NOTED THAT I AM A FIVE OH FOUR
STUDENT WAS AN I. E. P. PLAN.
SO I HAVE LEGAL ACCESS TO
COUNSELOR AS NEEDED.
HE WANTED ME TO GO TO HIS OFFICE.
BUT I SAID I WANT TO SPEAK TO MY
COUNSELOR.
AS I START TO WALK IN HER
DIRECTION HE TOLD ME THAT I WAS
SUSPENDED.
BECAUSE HE WANTED ME TO GO TO
HIS OFFICE ACT ON WHAT GROUNDS
HE SAID WELL FOR DEFIANCE.
I WAS SENT HOME BUT THAT MORNING
MY NANA CAME TO SCHOOL WITH MY
COUNSELOR. TO HAVE A MEETING
WITH HIM AND THE FELLOW DEAN'S.
THEN HE AGREED TO MEET TO LET ME
COME BACK TO SCHOOL.
IF I DID SATURDAY SCHOOL.
AFTER THIS EVENT HAPPENED I HAD
A COMPLICATION OF MY HEALTH
ISSUES AS A YOUNG GIRL I WAS
DYING OF CYSTIC Là FUNDING SAYS
DROP.
IN -- BOUNCING FROM OPPOSED TO
MAKE STRESS DISORDER.
COMBINED SIDE OF ALL OF THIS I
WILL BE GRADUATING IN JUNE
ATTENDING CINEMA STATE WITH A
MAJOR POLITICAL SCIENCE AND THE
PRE MED PROGRAM.
PLEASE SUPPORT SB [inaudible]
FOUR NINETEEN THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
YOU CAN ADD ON AT THIS TIME NAME
AN ORGANIZATION.
HI MY NAME IS ARE YOU TIMES FROM
THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION AND
I'LL PROBABLY START OF BY SAYING
ON THIS BILL WOULD BE THE FIRST
STARTED IN IN THE SCHOOL TO JOE
TRACK AND ME MY EXPERIENCE OF
BEING.
PUSHED OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL -- I
WOULD'VE BEEN AS HIGH SCHOOL ONE
THREE SURE GOT PUSHED OFFER LIKE
DEFIANCE IN LIKE BEING
DESTRUCTIVE IN A I WAS OUT OF
SCHOOL FOR LIKE A COUPLE OF
MONTHS.
AGO IN A KIND OF JUST MAKES YOU
FEEL LIKE THEY STILL YOU KNOW
EDUCATION FROM.
AND IT IN THE LONG RUN A REALLY
DON'T HELP YOU SO.
I FEEL LIKE I WOULD BE A PRO
BECAUSE ONCE YOU'RE.
IN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK.
CAN WE GO ALSO FROM THE JUSTICE
COALITION PROUD TO BE A CO
SPONSOR THANK YOU.
DEBORAH ESCRIBIR THE LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS A CO
SPONSORED SPONG STRONG SUPPORT.
BECAUSE OF AN ENEMY IS NOT TO
KNOW WHAT CHILDREN NOW PRACTICAL
SPONSORS SUPPORT PEACE
LEGISLATION.
Q..
NICK ROMAN WE HAVE A SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
HE WON CARILLO AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND SUPPORT.
IN THE GARAGE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT.
DANIEL KESSLER KAISER ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
CHARLES MY NAME IS NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW IN SUPPORT.
EXASHARE MOUNT ON BEHALF OF
FOLLOWERS IN FAMILIES SAN
JOAQUIN IN SUPPORT.
ALEXIS BERRIES YOUTH ADVOCATE
INSTRUCTS STRONG SUPPORT.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WESTON SUPPORT.
JIMMY FORGET ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
JANICE PO JITTERS GRANDMOTHER IN
SUPPORT.
AND OUR REPRESENTING THAT BLACK
HELLO SCHOOL BOARD.
BARBER HEARD JESUS GREAT AUNT
AND SUPPORT REPRESENTING SACK
ACT AND IF MY DAD WAS ALIVE
GEORGE HEARD.
HE WOULD BE SUPPORTING TO AS
WELL [inaudible]
THE QUEUE.
CAROL BECAUSE OF OUR CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT -- ESPANA
NEWS WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MENDOZA WITH THE ENTIRE
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN SUPPORT.
WESLEY SEVERAL JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH IN SUPPORT.
TEST PARCLO WESTERN CENTER ON ON
PARTY IN SUPPORT.
MY HOW IT MARCOS ON BEHALF OF
YOUTH FORWARD AND STUDENTS -- I
FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL I ALSO
ATTENDED SACK HIGH -- ALSO
ATTENDED RIO AMERICANO WHICH WAS
PREDOMINANTLY.
WHITES SO THIS ISSUE IS NOT JUST
WITHIN OUR BLACK STUDENTS BUT
ALSO WITHIN OUR ALL STUDENTS.
CAME IN DEAN -- FROM BOTH THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AND POLICY LINK -- PROUD
CO SPONSORS PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS AND THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER.
GOOD MORNING EMILY ELECTS UP IN
PRAGUE CO SPONSOR FROM THE
BROTHERS THEMSELVES COALITION
AND YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HAS ALSO SUSPENDED IN HIGH
SCHOOL FOR HAVING A SHARPIE MY
BACKPACK SO THANK YOU SIR.
SHE CHAU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE PULL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
BILL'S BEEN MOTIONS.
SO CENTER SKINNER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- I THINK THE
TESTIMONY SPOKE WELL AS WELL AS
THE WITNESSES AND I ASKED FOR A
VOTE.
VERY GOOD CLERK.
ITEM THREE SB FOUR NINETEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
LEYVA WILK HI WILK I CHIANG LU
ASAL.
LUNA SO I'D GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
SO SENATOR YOU HAVE TO AYE VOTES
IT WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU.
I KNOW THERE'S MANY COMMITTEES
THIS MORNING [inaudible]
AND WE'VE.
HAVE CALLS OUT TO AUTHORS SO
WE'RE GONNA SHUT DOWN UNTIL
SOMEBODY SHOWS UP
.
WELCOME CONGRESSMAN MY CASKEY.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ITEM TEN SB
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE AND THE
RECOMMENDATION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PROCREATION THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY STATING THAT I WILL.
ACCEPT.
OR WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT ON PAGE FIVE
OF THE ANALYSIS.
NOW SB. FIVE EIGHT FIVE DIRECTS
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH A
PLAN FOR TRANSITIONING NON
UNIFIED.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I COME AT THIS AS A BANKRUPTCY
REORGANIZE OR SO I LOOK AT
THINGS DIFFERENTLY VERSES AND
THAT PER SE EDUCATION APPROACH
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
HAVE BEEN A STATE.
IN THE STATE AND LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY FOR OVER SEVENTY YEARS
EXAMPLES OF PREVIOUS ACTIONS
INCLUDE THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
BUREAU SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ORGANIZATION BUT A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT AVERAGE EDUCATION IN.
NINETEEN FORTY NINE MAJOR
LEGISLATION IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FOUR BY DENSE ASSEMBLY SPEAKER
CHESS ANDREW -- WHICH OFFERED
NEW INCENTIVES FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT UNIFIED AND
DISINCENTIVES. FOR THOSE THAT
DID NOT IT SETS STANDARDS
REGARDING DISTRICTS SIZE AND
PHYSICAL ABILITY TO SERVE OUR
STUDENTS.
AND AS THE RECENTLY AS NINETEEN
NINETY NINE JUST A MERE TWENTY
YEARS AGO A RESOLUTION BY
SENATOR -- DEDE ALPERT WHO'S THE
FORMER CHAIR OF THIS VERY
COMMITTEE CREATING A NEW MASTER
PLAN FOR EDUCATION WHICH PUSH
FOR UNIFICATION OF ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
LOCAL -- CONTROL FORMULA
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES CREATED BY
MOST OF THE LEGISLATION THAT
ENCOURAGING OF CATION ARE NO
LONGER IN PLACE.
SO UNIFICATION OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAS ALREADY SHOWN WITH.
HAS ALREADY SLOWED.
WITH THE LACK OF A CONTINUE
FISCAL FISCAL INCENTIVES -- IT'S
DOUBTFUL THAT MANY OR ANY
DISTRICTS WILL PUSH PURSUE
UNIFICATION AT THIS TIME EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE.
THE COMMON CORE.
ACT -- CURRICULUM AND NEXT
GENERATION SCIENCE STANDARDS
WHICH WHICH DEMAND REQUIRE A
CONTINUUM OF OF ACADEMIC.
UNDERSTANDING AT EACH GRADE
LEVEL AS WE GO THROUGH THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM UNIFIED'S
DISTRICTS PROVIDE MANY BENEFITS
FOR STUDENTS.
AND THE COMMUNITY STEPPED THE
STE SERVE FINANCIALLY.
IN FACT DISTRICTS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO POOL RESOURCES REDUCE
OPERATION ALL COSTS AND PROVIDE
FOR A SINGLE STREAMLINED
ADMINISTRATION THE CHEAPER
FISSION SEES OF SCALE WE ALL
DESIRE HERE AT THE STATE LEVEL.
THESE TYPES OF COST SAVINGS
ALLOW FOR MORE FUNDS TO GO
DIRECTLY TO THE CLASSROOM WHICH
IS WHAT WE WANT TO PROVIDE
PROGRAMS TO DELIVER ENHANCE
EDUCATIONAL OFFERING TO STUDENTS
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT PROVIDES
STUDENTS.
A COORDINATING.
MATRICULATION THAT IS SUPPORTED
AND BUILT UPON THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE.
K. TWELVE SYSTEM EXPERIENCE.
MANY OF YOU KNOW MY WIFE IS
GETTING A DOCTORATE DEGREE IN
EDUCATION SHE TALKS ABOUT.
THIS OBSESSIVELY ALL THE TIME
ABOUT THE NEED TO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AT THESE
DIFFERENT GRADE LEVELS CAN HOW
THERE'S PUSH BACK -- FOR COMMON
CORE STILL TODAY AND AND NEXT
GENERATION SCIENCE STANDARDS
EVEN THOUGH ALL THE MATERIAL AND
HER THESIS WILL FOCUS ON THIS.
POINTS OUT THAT IT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IN SIMPLE WROTE
MEMORY IS A THING OF THE PAST
ALTHOUGH I'M VERY GOOD AT REAL
MEMOR.
AS NOTED IN YOUR ANALYSIS MISTER
VICE CHAIR THERE ARE ISSUES OF
INSTRUCTIONAL MISALIGNMENT
BETWEEN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND STUDENTS
TRANSITION INTO THE LOCAL HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SENATEBILL FIVE EIGHT FIVE IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP IN PROVIDING
OUR STUDENTS WITH.
WHICH SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
OPERATE IN THE MOST COORDINATED
EFFICIENT AND EQUITABLE WAY
POSSIBLE.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT IS
PERTINENT TO ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS.
INCLUDING MINE.
AND WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
MICHELLE REAVIS WHOSE THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE TWIN RIVERS.
A SCHOOL BOARD OF TRUSTEES
THANK YOU SENATOR MISTER VICE
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME OFF A LITTLE BIT
THE YOU'RE SITTING THERE NOW I
KNOW YOU SOMETHING ELSE I FORGOT
YOUR SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS WELL
YEAH I DON'T GET TO WEAR MY
SCHOOL BOARD HAD VERY OFTEN IN
THIS BUILDING SO I I REALLY.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR.
SO IT'S A SENATOR STATED ON THE
VICE PRESIDENT THE TWIN RIVERS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH IS
THE RESULT OF THE UNIFICATION OF
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I WAS A PART OF THOSE EFFORTS IT
TOOK OVER TEN YEARS TO MAKE THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT REALITY MANY
ATTEMPTS HAVE BEEN MADE WHEN YOU
ASK PEOPLE TO CONSIDER UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS A VERY
EMOTIONAL ISSUE FOR A LOT OF
FOLKS AND THE REALITY IS THAT
YOU'RE WORKING TO PUT YOURSELF.
OUT OF A JOB AND IT'S DIFFICULT
TO GET TRUSTEES TO AGREE TO DO
THAT IT'S DIFFICULT TO GET
SCHOOL DISTRICT ADMINISTRATORS
TO AGREE TO DO THAT.
BUT IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT WHAT'S
BEST FOR KIDS UNIFICATION IS
BEST FOR KIDS AND EDUCATION
THEIR PROVIDES FOR OPPORTUNITIES
THAT YOU MAY NOT HAPPEN TO
DISTRICT THAT ISN'T UNIFIED.
IT PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
TEACHERS TO WORK TOGETHER SO
THAT THEY CAN HELP THOSE KIDS
MOVE FROM.
FROM THE VARIOUS GRADE LEVELS
AND FROM ELEMENTARY TO SECONDARY
EDUCATION SO FROM A STRICTLY
EDUCATIONAL PERSPECTIVE.
AGAIN UNIFICATION IS INCREDIBLY
BENEFICIAL TO KIDS AND I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT BELL AGAIN IT'S
A VERY DIFFICULT PROCESS TO GO --
TO THROUGH IF IT'S DONE BY A
VERY SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITHOUT
THIS KIND OF GUIDANCE AND AGAIN
IT'S IT'S REALLY A BENEFIT TO
STUDENTS IN THE STATE SOME.
HAPPY TO BE HERE SUPPORTING THIS
LEGISLATION HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ANYONE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
BY STAFF -- IT DOES YOUR STAFF
OKAY PORTS BILL THANK YOU SHE
ARE YOU SURE I LIKE HER SPEAK
HONOR ON BEHALF -- ANY OTHERS
[inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
OKAY YOU JUST LEAVING OKAY
MOVING STE CHAIRS OKAY DON'T
MESS WITH ME.
I KNOW YOU ARE NOW [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW IS A PULL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU UP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- JUST IS THERE A
QUICK WAY OF DESCRIBING.
THE PROCESS IN.
YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU FIGURE OUT
WHICH SCHOOLS OR WHAT THE MERGER.
I THINK I'M USING THE TERM
pMERGER SORRY -- WOULD WOULD BE
LIKE I THINK THE WORD WHAT I
ENVISION IS A DISPASSIONATE.
REVIEW OF OF OF OF THE DAY WELL
THAT'S WHY WE'RE STARTING OFF
WITH HAVING CD HE COME UP WITH
THE PLAN BECAUSE WE SAT DOWN AND
SAID HERE.
PTA.
AND TEACHERS AND EVERYBODY COME
IN AND TELL US WHAT YOU THINK
WE'VE TRIED THAT FOR FIFTY YEARS
THAT'S THAT'S MY COULD WORK WITH
THE PLAN HERE IS THAT WE GO BACK
WE LOOK AT REMEMBER WE'RE NOT
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT -- I
HAVE TO BE UNIFORM I DON'T I
WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S NOT ALL THE
SAME SIZE AS A MATTER KIDS IS
JUST UNIFIED AND LOOK AT THE
LOOK AT THE AREA AND FIND OUT
YOU KNOW SOME.
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SO THEIR OWN
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
COMPLETELY SURROUNDED BY OTHER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT'S AN EASY
THAT'S SAN JOSE AND I'VE GOT.
I'VE GOT ALL KINDS OF PEOPLE
THAT HE DOES OKAY SO WE GET THAT
BUT OTHERS ARE LOOKING AT YOU
LOOK AT THE GEOGRAPHY AND FINCH
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS.
DISPASSIONATELY WHAT MAKES SENSE
TO TO HAVE THIS ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL BUT SEE YOU HAVE A AT
JUST ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT
MAYBE IT WORKS IF YOU MOVE FROM
ALL OVER HERE TO THIS HIGH
SCHOOL AND YOU SPIN OFF ONE OF
THE HIGH SCHOOL SO IT.
IT WORKS OFF AND IT IT'S IN THE
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT OR MAYBE
YOU PLUG THEM INTO THE ADJOINING
DISTRICTS OR MAYBE YOU BRING A
HIGH SCHOOL.
OUT OF A UNIFIED HOUSE HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN AND JUST MAKE
A DISTRICT ON ITS OWN SO THERE'S
A THERE'S DIFFERENT.
POSSIBILITIES BUT AGAIN WE'D
LIKE TO HAVE THEM WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE TO DISPATCH.
THIS PASSIONATE.
DRAWING A LINE SINCE SUGGESTION
AND THEN THE VIGOROUS IN -- A
HEALTHY DEBATE THAT GOES ON WITH
THAT AND I THINK IT IS NOT THAT
THAT THIS IS THE ONE LINE THAT
ENDS IT BUT BUT WE'D LIKE TO AT
LEAST HAVE THE MECHANISMS WHY WE
THINK IT.
IT WOULD ALLOW FOR BETTER
OUTCOMES OF STUDENTS AND WE
ALREADY HAVE A REQUIREMENT ON
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT I MEAN I THINK
I CAN SEE A LOT OF THIS SAYING
WE'RE GOOD THIS IS A HEALTHY.
COMMUNITY.
WE'RE GOING TO ADD THIS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL BECAUSE YOU
GUYS HAVE A GOOD TAX BASE YOU DO
THIS IN AND WE'RE GOING TO
DEMAND THAT YOU BRING IT UP TO
PERFORMANCE WHICH IS I THINK
IT'S A GOOD [inaudible]
DISPASSIONATE [inaudible]
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
THE BILL.
GREAT OUT SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
I THINK WE I THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS SO I HAVE THREE
GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS IN MY ONE
REGION WHERE I LIVE.
WE HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHICH IS QUITE LARGE AND WE HAVE
FOUR VERY SMALL.
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS.
ISSUES IS JOB DUPLICATION OF
SERVICES -- SO THE HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT DID A STUDY LIKE TWELVE
YEARS AGO MISSION THERE WERE
SAVE AT LEAST FOURTEEN MILLION A
YEAR -- BUT PEOPLE VIEWED IT AS
A AS A POWER GRAB SO I WAS
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND WE
MOVE FORWARD ON THIS I'M GONNA
BRING YOU DOWN TO ME AND MY
CONSTITUENTS WHEN THEY START --
YEAH MOVIE BE UNIFIED A BRING MY
PIN YADA [inaudible]
THERE'S THERE'S A SLOW UP A SLUG
OF A REPORTS IN A ONE NUMBER
BEING BANTER AROUND THIS IS
UNITED STATES.
TWENTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS
THAT WOULD BE SAFE ON CHOOSE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STUFF THAT COULD
GO TO THE CLASSROOMS AND I THINK
THAT'S MY PITCH AND I REMEMBER
IS AN AYE VOTE.
YOUR QUESTION YOU MEET YOU MADE
THAT EFFORT -- WITH WATER
DISTRICTS A FEW YEARS AGO IN
FACT YOU HELP ME WITH MY BILL TO
COMBINE TO WATER DISTRICTS IN
THE ALREADY THE FIRST YEAR.
WAY MORE MONEY THEY SAY THE
FIRST YEAR THEY THOUGHT THEY
WERE GONNA SAVE IN FIVE YEARS SO
THEY CERTAINLY WITH ECONOMY THE
SCALES BETTER AS MENTIONED BY
THE SCHOOL TRUSTEE.
YOU KNOW COORDINATION GOING
THROUGH IT SHOULD BENEFIT KIDS
SO WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
AND IT THE RECOMMENDATIONS DO
FAST AS AMENDED.
AND THANK YOU DECLARE YOU WERE
CLOSE AGAIN GO AHEAD I REALLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE NOW.
ITEM TEN SB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
WILK HI WILK I CHIANG THE LAST.
DURACELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
ZERO THE BILL'S OUT LAST YEAR
NOW BILLS NOT OUTS ON CALL
[inaudible]
AND RUBIO.
PHONE SENATOR RUBIO IS HERE.
COME ON UP [inaudible] SIX YOU
NEED FOR A LITTLE WHILE.
FIVE DO YOU HAVE A PERFECT --
PARTICULAR ORDER YOU'D LIKE TO
TAKE HIM IN OR WE CAN JUST
EGGMAN FILE ORDER.
AND I BELIEVE I HAVE ON THE FILE
FOR MYSELF OKAY.
SO WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS
[inaudible] EIGHTY TWO OKAY SO
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A FILE ITEM SIX
SP FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT THE
RECOMMENDATION IT.
ASA -- SENATOR DROSS IS GONNA
EVEN IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
SHE WANTED TO EXPRESS OF YOUR
MIND CAN I TAKE.
SB FIVE NINETY FOUR FIRST.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT IS ITEM ELEVEN
SB FIVE NINETY FOUR THE
RECOMMENDATION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED. TO TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SO WHENEVER YOU'RE.
READY GO AHEAD AND PROCEED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I AM PRESENTING
TODAY PROUDLY SB FIVE NINETY
FOUR WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
INDUSTRY ON A ROAD MAP
INITIATIVE.
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE SB FIVE
NINETY FOUR WOULD PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE TO O LAYS
ON THE IMPLANT IMAGE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OLD ROAD
MAP. FOR THE PURPOSE OF ENSURING
EFFECTIVE INAPPROPRIATE BEST
PRACTICES INSTRUCTION AND
SERVICES FOR OUR E. ALL STUDENTS
I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT CHAIR IN
HIS TOP FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE.
AND I WILL GLADLY ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFYING THE ROLE
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE WITH THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY EIGHT IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WE REMOVE MANY
OTHER LEGAL BARRIERS RELATED TO
MEETING THE NEEDS OF OUR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
EDUCATIONAL.
INSTRUCTION HUGHES IN THE
CLASSROOMS THEN IN JULY TWELFTH
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED
HISTORIC NEW POLICY FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS.
SUPERSEDING THE NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT INDUSTRY -- POLICY
STEMMING FROM A PROPOSITION
PROPOSITION TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
AND NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
ACCORDING TO THE C..
A D. E. AND LISTED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS THE OVERALL TWENTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN FOR
YOUR CALL HEARD GRADUATED.
GRADUATION WAS 91% WHILE THE
RATE FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS WAS
65% THE LOWEST OF ANY SUBGROUP
ASIDE STUDENTS IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
IN ADDITION THE DROP OUT RATE
FOR INDUSTRY EARNERS AT 21% WITH
THE HIGHEST OF ANY SUBGROUP AS
WELL.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT CDP
IN COLLABORATION WITH C. C. E.
WILL ESTABLISH AN E. L. ROAD MAP
THAT WOULD FURTHER SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS.
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS
PROVIDING A BETTER EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOME THIS BILL WILL ALSO
REQUIRE A WRITTEN REPORT ABOUT
THE PROGRAM THAT WILL SUBMIT.
I'M SORRY THAT WILL BE SUBMITTED
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON OR BEFORE
JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AND TODAY I HAVE HERE LISA
RUMOR AS SORRY LISA REMEMBERS
FROM TULARE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SHE WILL COVER WHAT IS
CURRENTLY HAPPENING IN THE FIELD
AND HOW THIS BILL CAN SUPPORT
OUR EDUCATORS.
AS WELL AS GET OFF THE ALARM.
I GARCIA TAURUS FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
SHE WILL ELABORATE ON THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
TRAINING FOR TEACHERS PARENTS
AND EDUCATION LEADERS ON HE'LL
THROW THEM THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ONE OF THE S. MY
NAME IS CRISTINA GARCIA VOTERS
WITH THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
I AM THE TITLE THREE REGION
THREE E. L. SPECIALIST OR
ENGLISH CENTER SPECIALIST
CALIFORNIA HAS UNDERGONE MAJOR
SHIFTS IN PEDAGOGY AND POLICY
DEVELOPMENT SPECIFIC TO ENGLISH
LEARNERS.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS WE
NOW HAVE ACADEMIC COMMON CORE
STANDARDS ENGLISH LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT ALONG TO THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS AND THEN HE'LL
LATE YOU'LL THE FRAMEWORK.
MOST RECENTLY THE PASSAGE OF THE
PROPOSITION FIFTY EIGHT IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
UNLOCKED THE POSSIBILITY OF
FIGHTERS THE FOR ALL STUDENTS
ATTENDING OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THESE CHANGES REGARDING SERVICES
PROGRAMS AND INSTRUCTION FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS CALL FOR AN
EVALUATION OF THE EXISTING STATE
POLICIES SPECIFIC TO YOUR
STUDENTS AND ON JULY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION.
APPROVES OF CALIFORNIA
ENGLISHMAN ROADMAP STRAINING
COMPREHENSIVE EDUCATIONAL
POLICIES PROGRAMS AND PRACTICES
FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS ALSO KNOWN
AS THE CALIFORNIA YOUR ROAD MAP.
THAT YOU'LL ROAD MAP PROVIDES
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY OF DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOLS AROUND EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESSING.
THE DISTINCT NEEDS OF YELLS NOW
IS THE TIME TO IMPLEMENT THAT
YOUR ROADMAP AS PART OF THAT
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE COMING
FROM THE COUNTY OFFICES OF ED.
SCURRY ALONG WITH THE CD HAS
PROVIDED TRAINING SESSIONS TO
ELLIE ACE ON THAT YOUR ROAD MAP
BUT THERE IS STILL SUBSTANTIAL
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
SB FIVE NINETY FOUR AS AMENDED
WE'LL OFFER CRITICALLY NEEDED
FUNDING AND FURTHER GUIDANCE AT
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS.
AS THE FIVE NINETY FOUR WILL
PROVIDE CRUCIALLY NEEDED SUPPORT
TO FULLY IMPLEMENT THAT YOU'LL
ROAD MAP.
AND GIVE ENGLISH LEARNERS THE
OPTIMAL OPPORTUNITY. TO BUILD A
COMPETITIVE EDGE IT WILL EQUIP
CALIFORNIA'S TEACHERS WITH THE
RIGHT TOOLS.
BUILD UPON STUDENTS ASSETS AND
HE WILL GIVE ADMINISTRATORS
THEIR WAY TO SUPPORT THE SYSTEMS
THAT MAKE IT HAPPEN INSTRUCTION --
STRUCTURAL AXIS SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS FOR ALL STUDENTS FOR
THESE REASONS THE SECOND
ACCOUNTING OFFICE SUPPORTS SB.
FIVE NINETY FOUR PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MR VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ALICIA WHAT I MADE AS
AND I AM A PROUD CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATOR MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS.
I WILL PUT THE TULARE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN THE HEART
OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND I
FULLY SUPPORT SB.
FIVE NINETY FOUR WHICH IS STAB
WISHES THE ENGLISHMAN A ROADMAP
INITIATIVE TO BETTER TRAINED
EDUCATORS SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN AS LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
IT WAS MY DESIRE IS A CHILD TO
BE PRIVY TO THE LANGUAGES SPOKEN
AROUND ME.
LEARNING ENGLISH FIRST I WAS
KEENLY AWARE OF THE FACT THAT I
WAS ONLY ABLE TO UNDERSTAND HALF
OF MY GRANDMOTHER'S WORLD.
GROWING MY CAPACITY FOR LANGUAGE
IN ADDITION TO ENGLISH ACROSS MY
EDUCATIONAL YEARS ALLOWED ME TO
STRENGTHEN FAMILIAR
RELATIONSHIPS.
REESTABLISH CULTURAL TIES
CULTIVATE A DIVERSE COMMUNITY OF
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES AND
IMPROVE MY CAPACITY FOR
COMMUNICATION.
IT ALSO PROVIDED ME IN CONTEXT
OF EMPATHY AS I ESTABLISHED MY
PATH AS AN EDUCATOR.
EVERY CHILD DESERVES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR BY LITERACY.
TAYLOR COUNTY CONSISTS OF 26% OF
ENGLISH LEARNERS BUT IN SOME
DISTRICTS AS HIGH AS 69% ENGLISH
LEARNERS.
THIS WEEK AS I WORKED WITH
TEACHERS AND SCHOOLS I SUPPORT
I'D ASK STUDENTS WHAT VALUE THEY
FIND IN KNOWING MORE THAN ONE
LANGUAGE.
SEVERAL PROCLAIM THAT IT MADE
HIM SMARTER.
HIM AND I'M NOTED THAT IT HELPED
HER TO HELP OTHER PEOPLE.
EFRAIN SAID KNOWING MORE THAN
ONE LANGUAGE AND ABLE CAN TO
UNDERSTAND OTHER KIDS.
WHAT KAYLA WITH FORESIGHT TO THE
FUTURE RECOGNIZE THAT WHEN SHE
GOES TO WORK ONE DAY SHE WILL BE
ABLE TO TALK TO DIFFERENT PEOPLE
AND THEY WILL UNDERSTAND ONE
ANOTHER?
ACKNOWLEDGING THE COMMUNICATION
INVOICE ARE FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR
DEMOCRACY AND OUR ECONOMY
WOMEN'S KAMINER RESOURCES AND
INVEST IN THE FUTURE OF OUR
CHILDREN SO THAT EACH CHILD HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY THREE LANGUAGE.
TO ENGAGE WITH AND REPRESENT THE
FULL EXTENT OF OUR SOCIETY.
I CAN TELL THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT SB FIVE NINETY FOUR AS-WE WORK TO ENHANCE THE CAPACITY
OF EDUCATORS TO IMPLEMENT THE
FULL VERSION OF THE CALIFORNIA.
ENGLISH LEARNER ROADMAP POLICY
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PERSON WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
OR DO WE ALREADY DO ALL THE
WITNESSES VERY SORRY --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR -- KATHY WINTER
PRESENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
LANGUAGE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING A MAJOR FORWARD.
MARCH EXCUSE ME MARTHA YEAR AGO
CITY AS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND WE ARE
CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
AND WERE IN STOCK STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HOUSE OF AN ENEMY DOES NOT SEND
OUR CHILDREN NOW PROUD TO
COSPONSOR THIS POOR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
JEFF FROST CALIFORNIA --
TEACHERS OF ENGLISH TO SPEAKERS
OF OTHER LANGUAGES AND SUPPORT.
CAROL CLOSE OF OUR CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA AND SUPPORT.
IN THE GARAGE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
THEY'RE A LOS TO TEACH PLUS IN
SUPPORT.
LEIGH ANGELA READ ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND IMPERIAL COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ANGELA MAGNERA TURNER PUBLIC
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND WE SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR RAZA.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL -- BUT
ALSO -- THANK SENATOR RUBIO --
FOR ALL YOUR WORK AND AND THE
COMMITTEE.
YOU KNOW GROWING UP IN MY
HOUSEHOLD -- BOTH MY PARENTS
SPOKE SPANISH AND ONLY SPANISH
MY FATHER DID HIS BEST TO LEARN
ENGLISH HE DIDN'T HAVE MUCH OF A
FORMAL EDUCATION BUT HE LIKE TO
READ A NEED.
ALWAYS TRY TO READ AND AN
ENGLISH AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE SO --
I GREW UP IN MY SISTERS AND
BROTHERS AND I FIGURED OUT THAT
BY LEARNING ENGLISH WE COULD SAY
THINGS THAT OUR PARENTS DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND.
AND SO WE GOT AWAY WITH A LOT OF
THINGS -- THAT WAS THE ADVANTAGE
I THOUGHT OF THAT BEING
BILINGUAL -- PROVIDED BUT IN
MORE IMPORTANTLY IS -- I FIND
TODAY I AM SO GRATEFUL THAT I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
SPANISH I TRY TO IMPROVE IT AS I
AS I GREW OLDER -- BUT IT'S
MEANT SO MUCH ESPECIALLY -- IN
THE STATE OF OF CALIFORNIA SO --
I AGAIN OF SEE PERSONALLY AND I
SEE IT ALL THE TIME WITH
FAMILIES THAT I ENGAGE WITH HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. FOR CHILDREN TO
GROW UP LEARNING ENGLISH AS THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S NEEDED IN THIS
COUNTRY PERIOD I DON'T KNOW OF
ANY FAMILIES A DENIED THAT --
BUT ALSO SHOULDN'T FEEL ASHAMED
FOR SPEAKING ANOTHER LANGUAGE WE
HAVE -- FAMILIES FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD WE RESPECT THEIR
CULTURES WE SHOULD RESPECT THEIR
LANGUAGES WHILE AT THE SAME TME
EMPHASIZING.
THE NEED TO SUCCEED IN THIS
COUNTRY IS WE HAVE TO LEARN
ENGLISH SO AGAIN I WANNA I WANNA
THANK YOU AND ALSO MENTIONED
THAT THE LATINO CAUCUS.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS HAS MADE THIS
ONE OF OUR PRIORITY OF PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT SOME POINT THE
SYSTEM THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS SO ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
ETCETERA RUBIO JUDGE CLOSE YES
THANK YOU -- OF FIRST PHONE AT
THANK ON SENATOR ALSO FOR HER
WORDS -- AND I COME TO YOU NOT
NECESSARY JUST AS A SENATOR BUT
AS A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS WHO SPENT MOST
OF MY CAREER TEACHING EMAIL
STUDENTS AND DINO WE WE TALK
ABOUT THE LATINO STUDENTS BUT I
HAD STUDENTS FROM ALL OVER.
THE WORLD AND SO THIS IS IT
HELPS EVERY CHILD STILL THINK
YOU AND I URGE YOUR RIFLE THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
SENATOR RUBIO THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR TO ROSAMOND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM ELEVEN SB FIVE NINETY FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK HI WILK I CHANGED
WOULD ASAL HI LUNA SO I GLAZER
MCGUIRE HANDS.
WE WILL HAVE LEAVE THAT BILL ON
CULTURE OTHER ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
TO ADD ON AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE WE
APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR RUBIO
DID YOU WANT TO MOVE ON TO FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT YES OKAY VERY GOOD
WE WILL -- PROCEED WITH AS
BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEETODAY I
AM PROUD TO PRESENT A SIMPLE BUT
VERY IMPORTANT BILL AS BEFORE.
SEVENTY EIGHT SB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT UPDATES THE MEMBERSHIP OF
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING BY REPLACING ONE
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WITH A
CERTIFIED HUMAN RESOURCE
ADMINISTRATOR.
THE CDC OVERSEES ALL ASPECTS OF
THE CERTIFIED.
BUT PLAY PROFESSION AMONG THE
MANY ROLES THE C. T. C. PLAYS A
DEVELOP AND AMEND CREDENTIALS TO
REFLECT CHANGES IN TEACHER AND
ADMINISTRATIVE PROFESSIONS.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO MEMBER OF
THE CTC WHO HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF HIRING AND
STAFFING THE SCHOOL OR DISTRICT
CURRENTLY THERE IS NOT I'M SORRY
WHAT THE COMPLEXITY OF
CREDENTIALING ASSIGNMENTS AND
STAFFING NEEDS.
I BELIEVE THE SIMPLE CHANGE TO
THE C. T. C. SHOULD BE MADE TO
REFLECT THE CHALLENGES AND NEEDS
OF OUR SCHOOLS TODAY I HAVE WITH
ME -- LARA PRESTON WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS.
THE SPONSOR OF SB.
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT VERY GOOD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF LAST TO
VIEW TO SPEAK TO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE LARA PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS.
THIS BILL CAME TO US FROM OUR
MEMBERS -- ESPECIALLY IN OUR
HUMAN RESOURCE UNIVERSE.
AS THE CTC THEIR WORK HAS
EVOLVED AND ISSUES OF THE
CREDENTIALING HAS BECOME MORE
MORE COMPLICATED AND COMPLEX.
WE REALLY FEEL THE NEED THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOMEBODY ON
THEIR A VOICE FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY DO THE HIRING AND
STAFFING OF THEIR SCHOOLS YES
THERE IS ONE ADMINISTRATOR ON
THERE.
IT'S A SUPERINTENDENT WHO --
DOES NOT NECESSARILY HAVE THAT
JOB THEY'RE ULTIMATELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE HIRING AND
FIRING BUT AND IT COULD MAKING
SURE YOUR CREDENTIALS ARE ARE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
HAPPENED ALSO.
IS UNDER ES AS A WE NOW ARE
REQUIRED TO ANNUALLY FIRE ALARM
THIS MESS OF MRS SIGN MINTS AND
SO IT'S EVEN MORE CRITICAL THAT
WE HAVE PEOPLE ON THERE WHO CAN
HELP IDENTIFY WHAT CREDENTIALS
ARE NEEDED AND WHERE THEY NEED
TO BE PLACED. TO URGE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF BACA
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
THE ONLY THING ALLOWED TO MISS
PRESTON'S COMMENTS IS THAT --
ONE OF THE FOLKS THAT
CONTRIBUTED TO THE AXE A
WORKGROUP -- THAT RESULTED IN
THIS RECOMMENDATION HE HAS -- DR
HEATHER WILLIAMS FROM THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND WE AGREE THAT THIS
IS A PERSPECTIVE THAT.
WOULD REALLY BENEFIT SOME OF THE
MORE DETAILED CONVERSATIONS THAT
TAKE PLACE AT THE CDC SO WE'RE
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO A THIRD
WHEN IT'S BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN
SUFFICIENT WITH YOUR TIME GO
AHEAD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JEFF FROST REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE
HAVE WORKED A LOT WITH THE CITY
SEE OVER THE YEARS.
THERE IS ONE ADMINISTRATOR -- TO
GO ALONG WITH THE BEVY OF
TEACHER REPRESENTATIVES WE THINK
AN ADDITIONAL -- ADMINISTRATIVE
PURSE POSITION -- SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO HUMAN RESOURCES WOULD
BE VERY VALUABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT NAME ORGANIZATION
PLEASE YES -- ISABEL GARCIA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL BUT
WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASS
THE BILL BECAUSE WE WE LIKE THE
CONCEPT AND WE WANT TO GET TO A
FORMAL POSITION.
AND WE THINK THIS IS A VALUABLE
EXPERTISE IT COULD BE UP BE
BROUGHT TO THE COMMISSION.
SO THAK YOU ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING HEARING NONE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR WELCOME MOVE THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES I
WILL FIRST OF ALL I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ALL THREE WITNESSES UP
HERE THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO COME UP AND UP.
PRESENT I'M JUST WANT TO CLOSE
WITH THAT THE HUMAN RESOURCE
ADMINISTRATOR CAN EFFECTIVELY
AND FORM THE COMMISSION MEMBERS
AND STAFF OF THE IMPACT OF THEIR
DECISIONS ON LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
I URGE YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
MADAM SECRETARY OF THE BILL'S
MEMO BY CENTER WILK MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SIX AS BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEAVE THE I WILL WILK AYE CHIANG
WHO ASAL.
USER MCGUIRE PAN.
WE HAVE TO YOU HAVE TO VOTES
WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL FOR
OTHER MEMBERS AND WE WILL MOVE
TO SB SIX FOURTEEN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY PLEASE PROCEED
.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M PROUD TO
INTRODUCE SB SIX ONE FOR A BILL
THAT WOULD EXTEND THE INCLUSIVE
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION ECT
GRANT PROGRAM.
LA OUT THE CRITERIA FOR AWARDING
FUNDS ALLOCATED THROUGH THIS
GRANT PROGRAM GRANT PROPOSALS
MUST DEMONSTRATE HOW COUNTIES
WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO
SUBSIDIZE INCLUSIVE EAZY E.
PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN UP TO FIVE
YEARS OLD.
PARTICULARLY THOSE AYE WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS AND LOW INCOME
OR HIGH NEED COMMUNITIES
RESEARCH SHOWS EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAMS CAN IMPROVE A
CHILD'S DEVELOPMENTAL PROGRESS
AN EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
ESPECIALLY FOR STUDENTS WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS THIS PROGRAM
CREATES A SENSE OF BELONGING
PROMOTES A POSITIVE SOCIAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
AND HELPS CHILDREN A
PARTICIPATING TO DEVELOP
IMPORTANT SKILLS.
TODAY WITH ME I HAVE PAMELA KISS
WITH THE LA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THAT WILL TESTIFY ON
MY BEHALF THANK YOU.
YOU SENATOR RUBIO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HI PAMELA.
HELLO THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING.
WE WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FOURTEEN AS MANY OF YOU
MAY KNOW OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION HAS A
VARIETY.
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
PROGRAMS SERVING OVER THIRTEEN
THOUSAND KIDS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY AND ALL OF THOSE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS.
SOME OF THOSE CHILDREN -- WE
HAVE ABOUT ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE OF THOSE
KIDS WHO ARE BIRTH TO FIVE YEARS
OLD.
SO GIVEN THAT WE THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO CONTINUE THE
OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT WERE
STARTED LAST YEAR WITH THE THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL AND WE THINK --
CONTINUING THESE EFFORTS WOULD
BE A VERY SIGNIFICANT LAKE COMO
SUPPORTS THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THEIR INCLUSIVE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION -- GRANT PROGRAM --
FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED WE ALSO KNOW THAT THEIR
BILL WAS SUPPORT.
PLACEMENT NAVIGATORS ACCORDING
NATION AND PROVISION OF
RESOURCES A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ASSESSMENTS.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WE BELIEVE
THE ASSESSMENTS AND EVALUATIONS
WILL HELP IMPROVE THE PROGRAM'S
GOING FORWARD AND SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT.
COME ON DOWN.
RON RAPPER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
ARE EXCUSE ME SUPPORTERS THIRTY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
CENTER WILK.
I MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR WELK SAID REVIEW WHICH I
TO CLOSE THANK YOU WELL ONCE
AGAIN I BRING MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AS A SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD PUBLIC SCHOOL.
TEACHER AND THREE YEARS AT THE
ADMINISTRATOR AND I SEE THAT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP SO I
URGE YOUR EYEBALLS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO MADAM
SECRETARY THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER WILL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ITEM TWELVE SB SIX ONE FOR THE
MOTION IS DO PAST HUMAN SERVICES
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE WILK HI WILK
I CHIANG.
LASSELL GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT BOUGHT A BILL
ON CALL AND YOU HAVE ONE MORE
BILLS SENATOR RUBIO -- SB SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
WHEN ACROSS ONE OF THOSE WATERS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
YOU'LL BE HAPPY TO KNOW THIS IS
THE LAST ONE I PROMISE THAT'S
OKAY YOU'RE GOOD AUTHOR WE LIKE
HAVING YOU HERE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM PRESENTING TODAY AS BE
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN WHICH WOULD
IMPROVE THE PERCENTAGE OF
COMMUNITYCOLLEGE INSTRUCTIONS
TAUGHT BY A FULL TIME FACULTY.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FIVE WHICH REFORM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MISSION AND GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
AND STATING THE IMPORTANCE OF
FULL TIME FACULTY IT ALSO
ESTABLISHED A GOAL THAT 75% OF
INSTRUCTION SHOULD BE TAUGHT BY
A FULL TIME FACULTY.
IT HAS BEEN MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS.
WHEN I SAY TO GET MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS SINCE THE STATE
ADOPTED THIS GOAL OF 75% AND IT
HAS YET TO BE ACHIEVED?
IN FACT DUE TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES GROWING OVER RELIANCE
ON TEMPORARY PART TIME FACULTY
THE LATEST DATA SHOWS THE FULL
TIME FACULTY TEACHING LEVEL AT
ONLY FIFTY SIX POINT 7%.
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN THAT COUNTS
FOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CONVENE TO WORK GROUP
MADE UP OF COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS.
AND FACULTY TO EXPLORE OPTIONS
TO REFORM TO KEY LAWS AND
REGULATIONS THE 75% GOAL AND THE
50% LAW.
I ALREADY EXPLAINED WHAT THE 75%
GOAL IS A THE 50% LAW BASICALLY
STATES THAT 50% OF COLLEGE
FUNDING IS SPENT ON INSTRUCTION.
THE MARCH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CONCERT IN MARCH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE WORKGROUP REPORTED
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ACHIEVE THE
75% FULL TIME FACULTY GOAL.
THE WORKER ALSO HOPE TO COME UP
WITH A RECOMMENDATION TO THE 50%
LAW -- BUT NO FORTY THEY'RE NOT
THERE YET BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
HAVE THE NECESSARY DATA FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM TO
PROPERTY DISCUSS POSSBLE
REFORMS.
I REALIZE SOME OF IF YOU WOULD-PREFER A FULL PACKAGE AS TO WHY --
BUT WE NEED MEANING.
I'M SORRY REALIZE THAT SOME OF
YOU WOULD PREFER THE FULL
PACKAGE BUT ANY REFORM PROPOSALS
FOR THIS ANY 5% GOAL.
AT THIS IS CALLED THE FUN
FACULTY OBLIGATION NUMBER AND
THE 50% LAW INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL -- BUT THIS BILL IS MEANT
TO INCORPORATE ONLY THOSE
REFORMS AGREED UPON BY THE WORK
GROUP ALREADY NOTHING MORE AND
NOTHING LESS.
OF THE WORKER DOES COME UP WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO AMEND THE BILL TO INCORPORATE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
AS WELL I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ADDRESS A COUPLE OF CONCERNS
RAISED ABOUT THE BILL. ONE IS A
CONCERN THAT THIS BILL WHICH
SHOULD.
ONLY BE ADOPTED UNLESS IT COMES
WITH MORE FUNDING BECAUSE FULL
TIME FACULTY COSTS MORE I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THE INCREASES IN
COST IS NOT. FOR FULL COST OF
FULL TIME FACULTY MEMBER BUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A PART TIME
FACULTY MEMBER ALREADY EMPLOYED
AND A FULL TIME.
EMPLOYEE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
ALREADY PAYING PART TIME FACULTY
I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT THE
STATE NOT ONLY GAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND THEIR USE OF FUNDS BUT IT
ALSO INCREASE THE FUNDING NO
DOUBT I WILL BE AN ARDENT
SUPPORTER MOVING FORWARD FOR
FIGHTING FOR MORE FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
BUT AT THIS POINT COLLEGES ARE
WAY BETTER OFF THAN THEY WERE A
FEW YEARS AGO SO IF NOT NOW WHEN
AND AGAIN THIRTY YEARS.
ANOTHER CONCERN I HEARD IS THIS
BILL IS PREMATURE BECAUSE THE
CHANCELLOR.
THE CHANCES CONSULTATION COUNCIL
HAS YET TO MEET AND REVIEW THE
WORK GROUPS OF RECOMMENDATIONS
MEMBERS THIS RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE PROPOSED OVER A YEAR AGO
THE COUNCIL MEETS FREQUENTLY.
AND I IMAGINE IT WOULD HAVE HAD
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THIS AND
HOW TIME. TO TO DISCUSS SOUL TO
ASK FOR THE BILL TO WAIT FOR THE
COUNCIL AND THEN THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS TO MEET IS TO
ESSENTIALLY ASKED FOR THE BILL
TO DYING COMMITTEE.
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE I ASKED THAT WE MOVE THE
BILL TODAY THE BILL IS NOT
NEEDED IN THE END THAT'S OKAY
BUT AT LEAST WE ENSURE WE DO NOT
TO LATE YET ANOTHER YEAR.
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE WAS FIRST.
MY FIRST ACCESS TO A TO A HIGHER
EDUCATION AS A FORMER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT I UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT FULL TIME FACULTY ARE
AND HOW MUCH WE NEED THEM IF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE GOING TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES.
AT OVER 43% OF LATINOS COMPRISE
THE LARGEST SEGMENT OF STUDENT
ENROLLMENT AND CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE NEXT
LARGEST GROUP IS WHITE AT 26% IN
GENERAL THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IS THE LARGEST.
MOST IMPORTANT POP PIPELINE TO
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR STATE.
LATINO POPULATION ACCORDING TO
TWENTY SIXTEEN REPORT BY THE PEW
RESEARCH CENTER LATINOS HAVE
MADE INROADS IN INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF COLLEGE ENROLLMENT BUT
TRY STICKY LACK BEHIND AND
COLLEGE COMPLETION.
DATA FROM TWENTY FOURTEEN SHOW
THAT ONLY 15% OF LATINOS AGE
TWENTY FIVE TO TWENTY NINE YEARS
OLD HAD A BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR
MORE COMPARED 263% OF ASIANS 41%
WHITES AND 22% BLACKS.
THIS TREND IS EXTREMELY
TROUBLING GIVEN THAT LATINOS ARE
NOW THE LARGEST ETHNIC GROUP IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE SIMPLE FACT THE FULL TIME
FACULTY CAN HOLD OFFICE HOURS
HIGHLIGHTS HOW.
HAVING STABLE EXPERIENCE AND
ACCESSIBLE FACULTY IS
SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT FOR STUDENT
OUTCOMES BECAUSE THE ECONOMY.
I'M SORRY BECAUSE ECONOMY
ECONOMIC FATE AND PROSPERITY OF
THE STATE WILL LIKELY REST ON
THE EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS OFFER
USE.
AND FUTURE STUDENTS IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DOES WHAT IT CAN TO INCREASE
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES I COMMUNITY
COLLEGES INCREASING THE RATE OF
INSTRUCTION BY FULL TIME FACULTY
IS CRITICAL TO REACHING THIS
GOAL WITHOUT CHANGING HOW OUR
STUDENTS ARE TAUGHT IT IS
DOUBTFUL.
WE ARE THE TOP OF THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS WILL EVER BE REALIZED SO
TODAY I'M HONORED TO HAVE
RECOUNTS AN AMOROUS MATH FACULTY
AT DE ANZA COLLEGE.
A PAST PRESIDENT OF EIGHT ACC A
MEMBER OF THE WORKGROUP THAT
WORKED ON THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
AS WELL AS DAVID BELL HAWKINS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INDEPENDENCE BONTA THE
BILL THANK YOU GENTLEMEN FOR
BEING HERE.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO WELCOME
GENTLEMEN YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU CENTER AT YOUR
LEYVA A VICE CHAIR WILL DAVID
BELL HAWKINS WITH THE COMMITTEE
KHALEEJ INDEPENDENCE -- YOU KNOW
THINK ABOUT MY TEST FOR THIS
MORNING AND THEN I CHANGED
EVERYTHING -- BECAUSE I'VE BEEN --
ACCUSED ORGANIZATION FINNICK USE
OF DOING SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
NOT EVER INTENDING TO DO.
SO FROM THE BEGINNING ALL THAT
WE WANTED TO DO WITH THIS BILL
WAS TO IMPLEMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS SAID HAD
UNIVERSAL AGREEMENT.
INCLUDING FROM TWO CHANCELLORS
AN EXECUTIVE VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
BUSINESS AND TECHNOLOGY AND AS
SUPERINTENDENT PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANTED TO DO THIS
BILL THAT'S WHAT WE TALKED WITH
SENATOR RUBIO ABOUT -- PEOPLE
ARE SAYING THEY WERE PREMATURE --
BECAUSE WE ONLY HAVE ONE PIECE
IN THE BILL THAT IS THE ONE THAT
WE HAVE UNIVERSAL AGREEMENT WE
DO HAVE AGREEMENT ON THE 50% LAW
ON A POLICY BASIS THAT'S ALSO IN
THE REPORT.
WE DON'T HAVE IT IS A NEW
PERCENTAGE NUMBER. THREE YEARS
AGO WE ASK FOR DATA FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE BECAUSE ONCE
WE FOLD IN FOR INSTANCE THE
CHANGE WOULD BE PRIMARILY
FOLDING IN CANCERS AND
LIBRARIANS IN THAT INSTRUCTIONAL.
PERCENTAGE.
SO WE'RE EXPANDING THE PART OF
WE STATE 50% THAT WE'RE GONNA BE.
KNOCKING PEOPLE OUT SO IT'S
PROBABLY FIFTY THREE MAYBE 54%
IS THE NEW PERCENTAGE.
BUT WE CAN'T WE CAN'T GAS AND
THAT FOR THREE YEARS WE'VE BEEN
ASKING FOR DAD AND WE HAVEN'T
HAD THE DATA SO UNTIL WE GET THE
DATA BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO PUT IT
IN THE BILL SO.
I'VE GOT LABOR UNIONS ASKING ME
FOR AMENDMENTS AND I'M TELLING
THEM NO BECAUSE IT'S NOT IN THE
REPORT [inaudible]
SO.
I'VE BEEN AROUND HERE A LONG
TIME.
ADMINISTRATORS AND FACULTY HAVE
NEVER BEEN NEVER AGREED ON THESE
ISSUES.
I HAVE NEVER AGREED ON THIS
LEASES ALL THIS IS ALWAYS BEEN
CONTENTIOUS SO WHEN AND EVERY TO
GIVE THE DETAILS WHEN I HEARD
THAT THERE WAS AN AGREEMENT AYE
I WAS REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THAT'S THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
WE'RE GONNA ACTUALLY IT MOVE
ALONG WITH FULL TIME FACT WHICH
IS GOING BACKWARDS BY THE WAY.
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS WE'VE LOST
CLOSE TO THREE PERCENTAGE POINTS
OUT WEIRD 56% NOW WE SHOULD BE
AROUND FIFTY NINE BUT THAT WAS
TEN YEARS AGO -- AND WE DIDN'T
WANT THIS TO SIT ON A SHELF --
AGAIN IT'S BEEN IN THE FIELD FOR
THREE YEARS THERE'S BEEN PLENTY
OF TIME FOR THE CANCERS OFFICE --
TO ACT ON THIS AND SO WE JUST
SAID WELL.
YOU KNOW CENTER RUBIO CAN YOU
CAN YOU TRUST US TO GET THIS
THROUGH JUST LIKE YOU KNOW THIS
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO -- WILL
REFLECT WHATEVER THE THE WORK
THAT WORK FORCE RECOMMENDATION
IS AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON SO --
BUT A COUPLE OF QUICK PIECES SO
JUNE TWO THOUSAND FIVE YOU ARE
USING UP YOUR CAR COLLEAGUES
TIME THEN I'M DONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME I
APPRECIATED [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I CAN PICK UP FROM RIGHT THERE
BECAUSE I SERVED ON THAT TASK
FORCE AS WELL IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE AND THEN I WAS INVOLVED IN
ALL OF THE WORK GROUP --
SESSIONS -- IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
ACTUALLY WE WERE AT THAT POINT
COMING OFF ABOUT A TEN YEAR
PERIOD WHERE OUR PERCENTAGE.
HOVERED AROUND 63% ACTUALLY SO
WE'VE ACTED AND WHEN WE ENTERED
INTO A RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN TWO YEARS LATER.
THAT'S WHEN THOSE NUMBERS THAT
DAVID LISTED THAT BECAME
OPERATIVE WE DROP DOWN BELOW
SIXTY AND NOW WE'RE DOWN AROUND --
FIFTY SEVEN I THINK IT'S THE
DYNAMICS OF THE CUTS AND THINGS
THAT HAPPENED DURING THOSE THOSE
YEARS BUT IT'S HARD TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT -- WOULD BE
THE CASE -- ONE THING I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO ADD TO THIS IS THAT
THIS WHOLE WORKGROUP CAME OUT OF
WHAT WAS CALLED.
THE SACRED COWS WORKSHOPS.
THEY WERE PRESENTED BY AND THEN
THE SACRED COWS ARE THE 50% LAW
AND THE 75% GOAL -- THE IT WAS A
GROUP OF ONE ACADEMIC SENATE --
PERSON THE PRESIDENT AT THE TIME --
BUSINESS OFFICER AND THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FROM THE
SYSTEM AND THEY HAD OPEN
MEETINGS WHERE THEY DISCUSSED
THESE -- PROBLEMS.
I DON'T KNOW THERE'S A MATTER OF
AGREEMENT OR NOT BUT WE'VE NEVER
BEEN ABLE TO MAKE PROGRESS ON
THE 75% GOAL AND WE ALSO HAVE
THE 50% LAW.
THAT -- SETS A REQUIREMENT FOR
THE DISTRICTS IN TERMS OF THEIR
SPENDING.
AND CENTER LATE -- SENATOR RUBIO
PUT IT RIGHT IT'S ALL ABOUT AND
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION.
BUT AS YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
REFORMED MIGHTILY WE'VE GOT NEW
MONEY TO ACTUALLY FIND LEASE --
FUND OUR STUDENTS SERVICES
SUPPORT OF FOR STUDENT SUCCESS
THAT'S A HUGE BREAKTHROUGH -- WE
WERE ALWAYS PAID SIMPLY FOR
STUDENTS IN CLASSROOMS LIKE A
TWELVE IS EIGHTY A FOR US FOR US
IT WAS ALSO ATTENDANCE.
NOW WE'RE FINALLY OVER THAT
HURDLE THIS IS THE TIME TO COME
TOGETHER THIS IS A ONCE IN A
LIFETIME POTENTIAL TO HAVE THESE
TWO ISSUES ADDRESSED -- BRING
THE STUDENTS SERVICE SIDE INTO
TE 50% LAW TO SOME LIMITED
EXTENT.
WE NEED THE DATA ON NOT TO BE
ABLE TO SET THAT NEW NUMBER.
AND THEN ALSO TO INSTITUTE A
MEANS OF GETTING THE FULL TIME
FACULTY WE NEED.
AND IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
INSTRUCTIONS ALL THE OTHER WORK
THAT GOES INTO STUDENT SUCCESS.
GUIDED PATHWAYS REQUIRES A LOT
MORE FACULTY MENTORING.
THAT'S HOW WE NEED FULL TIME
FACULTY TO DO THAT WORK SO THE
THE IT'S A NEXUS PERFECT TIME WE
CAN REALLY MAKE BIG CHANGES HERE
THAT WILL BE BENEFIT TO ALL OUR
STUDENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. SEVEN A
GOLDEN OF THE FACULTY-ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SEEN MEN'S ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
COME ON DOWN.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE -- MY NAME IS
RYAN MACLAINE AND I'M WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE A CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB -- SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN FIRST TO BE CLEAR -- WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS THIS MEASURE OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF FULL TIME
FACULTY -- THE AUTHOR I THINK
I'LL ELEGANTLY TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF FULL TIME FACULTY IN
THE CLASSROOM.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE ASPIRATIONAL
GOAL THAT OUR SYSTEM HAS OF
HAVING 75% OF OUR COURSE
INSTRUCTION TAUGHT BY FULL TIME
FACULTY.
HOWEVER.
WHEN THE GOAL WAS SAID?
IT WAS INTENDED THAT WE RECEIVE
PROGRAMMATIC IMPROVEMENT FUNDING
SO THAT WE COULD RECYCLE.
WE DID WE DID RECEIVE SOME
FUNDING FOR A FEW YEARS BUT
SINCE THEN -- DUE TO RECESSIONS --
ARE FUNDING REALLY ESTATE FLAT
ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION
[inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
UNFORTUNATELY AS THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM WITH THE LOWEST PER
PEOPLE FUNDING RATE -- IN THE
STATE EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
STUDENT.
COMPARED TO TWELVE THOUSAND K.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN OR EIGHTEEN AND
CSU AND TWENTY SEVEN AND YOU SEE.
OUR INSTITUTIONS MUST MAKE HARD
CHOICES ABOUT -- HOW BEST TO
IMPLEMENT LOCAL PRIORITIES --
IT'S A PRIORITIES.
AND THAT IS THE REASON WHY WE'VE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO INCREASE OUR
FULL TIME FACULTY MEMBERS --
THERE HAS BEEN SOME CONFUSION
ABOUT THIS REPORT -- WHICH FIVE
DISTRIBUTOR **** STARTIN TO
DISTRIBUTE -- TO MEMBERS ON THE
DíAS -- AND WHAT WAS INCLUDED
IN SB SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN AND WHAT
IS NOT INCLUDED IN THE REPORT --
SO FIRST IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE IS
A OMMITMENT TO INCLUDE ONCE WE
GET DATA AVAILABLE TO INCLUDE RE
BENCHING OF A 50% LAW AND BUT
LIKE TO THANK THE SPONSORS FOR
THAT -- HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE JUST NOT
INCLUDED. FOR EXAMPLE -- THE
REPORT -- HASN'T ASKED THAT A
SYSTEM CONSENSUS FORM AROUND THE
BILL OR BEFORE AROUND THE REPORT.
BEFORE ANY OF THE INITIATIVES
ARE IMPLEMENTED -- THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED.
AND THEN FINALLY THROUGHOUT THE
REPORT THERE'S BEEN STRONG
ADVOCACY FOR FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT THE BILL OR THE REPORT --
AND AGAIN WE JUST DO NOT SEE ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING COMING TO
HELP US IMPLEMENT -- THE TENETS
OF THIS REPORT SO. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE HOLD
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AWESOME
WEBSTER ON BEHALF OF THE COAST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
RANCHO SANTIAGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND ORANGE
COUNTY LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE.
WE HAVEN'T.
SUBMITTED ANY FORMAL OPPOSITION
BUT WE DO STRONGLY SHARE THE
CONCERNS -- OUTLINED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE AT THE LEAGUE -- AND
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
THAT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE --
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SENATOR WILK I HAVE A COMMENT I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING ON THIS
ISSUE IS A FORMER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE -- TRUSTEE FOR SIX YEARS
AND I KNOW THE TO LIKE THE 50%
LAW WAS PASSED THE YEAR I WAS
BORN.
AND NEED TO DRESS I TRY TO DO
THAT MY MY FRESHMAN YEAR UP HERE
IN CUT CHEWED UP.
I APPRECIATE YOUR BRAVERY --
TODAY I'M I'M NOT GONNA BE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I HAD TO MY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REACHED OUT
IN AN INNER OPPOSITION I'M
COMPANY YOU ARE GOING TO GET IT
OUT.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CONTINUE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND WE CAN GET TO
SEE -- SOMETHING THAT BENEFITS
ALL STUDENTS SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR WILK CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSER
TO RUBIO YES THANK YOU.
WELL THIS BILL IS ULTIMATELY
ABOUT THE SUCCESS OF OUR
STUDENTS AND GIVING OUR TEACHER
STABILITY AND I MEAN I KNOW EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NOT THE SAME I
EQUATE THIS TO BE A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER WHICH I DID FOR TWO
YEARS YOU BOUNCE AROUND AND
NEVER HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD.
A RELATIONSHIP WITH THE STUDENTS
THAT YOU SERVICE AND IT WASN'T
UNTIL I BECAME A FULL TIME
TEACHER THAT YOU START GETTING
MORE VESTED IN THE IN THE
STUDENTS PERSONALIZING GOING
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF YOUR JOB AND
THAT'S WHAT I HOPE THIS BILL
DOES.
THAT WE GET OUR TEACHERS MORE
INVESTED AND BECOME MENTORS AT
SOMEONE MENTION OF FALLOUT FOR
OUR LONG TERM SUCCESS STATE CAN
I URGE YOUR RIFLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO THE
BILL'S REMOVED BY SENATOR PAN
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM SEVENTEEN SB SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK NO WILK NO CHIANG
WHO ASSELIN.
Là ASSEGAI GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN HI.
WILL BE THERE ON CALL FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR RUBIO
SANDERS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I THINK I SEE CENTER
BRADFORD COME ON DOWN.
CENTER BRADFORD I THINK YOU HAVE
SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE WHENEVER
YOU ARE READY PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT.
SB FIVE SEVEN FIVE NO SOME MEN
DAHLE OFTEN STATED THE BEST
WEAPON FOR CHANGING THE WORLD IS
A GREAT EDUCATION.
AND WE OFTEN STATE THAT
EDUCATION IS THE GREAT EQUALIZER --
BUT WE MUST ASK OURSELVES FOR
HOME.
WE MUST ALSO OUT FOR SHOWS IF
WE'RE TRULY IF WE TRULY VALUE
EVERY STUDENT EVEN STUDENTS WHO
HAPPEN TO BE INCARCERATED AS
POLISHED AND POLICY MAKERS THAT
ANSWER SHOULD BE YES.
AND OF DANCERS YES WE MUST AGAIN
ASKS WHY.
THERE ARE BANDS ON CAL GRANT FOR
THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
INCARCERATION SHOULD NOT
AUTOMATICALLY DISQUALIFY
STUDENTS FROM CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
AND THAT IS WHY WE'RE PRESENTING
SB.
FIVE SEVEN FIVE SB FIVE SEVEN
FIVE REMOVED OUTDATED BEARS AN
EXPANSE ACCESS TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INCARCERATED
STUDENTS TO THE SECOND CHANCE
CAL GRANTS.
WHILE SUPPORTING EFFECTIVE
REHABILITATIVE EFFORTS WITH IN
OUR CORRECTIONAL INSTITUTIONS --
I WANT TO BE CLEAR PROVIDING
FINANCIAL AID TO INCARCERATED
STUDENT IT'S NOT A NEW CONCEPT --
WE'VE BEEN DOING IT SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THROUGH THE
HIGHER EDUCATION ACT.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA ANNOUNCES SECOND
CHANCE PAL PILOT PROGRAM TO
ALLOW THOSE INCARCERATED JUST
RECEIVED PELL GRANTS TO PURSUE.
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
PROVIDING THAT EDUCATION IS NOT
A PARTISAN ISSUE.
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
EXTENDED TO OBAMACARE PILOT
PROGRAM FOR FOURTH YEAR IS A
WISE CALIFORNIA NOT DOING THE
SAME AND AND AND WHAT WHEN THE
BENEFITS ARE CLEAR.
STUDENTS WHO ARE INCARCERATED IN
PARTICIPATING CORRECTIONAL --
EDUCATION HAVE 43% LOWER.
INCIDENCE OF RECIDIVISM AFTER
BEING RELEASED.
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT IS
CLEAR FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR
INVESTED ON CORRECTIONAL
EDUCATION RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT THERE IS A FORTY FIVE
DOLLAR RETURN.
ON INVESTMENT CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY SPENDS ON AVERAGE OF
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
TO HOUSING IN MAY YEAH THE
REVENUE NEEDED TO SUPPORT ONE
FULL TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT IS SLIGHTLY OVER FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ONE OF THE
MOST VALUE ASPECTS OF EDUCATION
IS THAT THAT INCREASES
OPPORTUNITY FOR EMPLOYMENT ONCE
RELEASE EMPLOYMENT AS THE BASIS
FOR BEING ABLE TO MEET ONCE
BASIC NEEDS FOR FOOD AND HOUSING.
WHAT EDUCATION ALONE DOES NOT
SOLVE ALL THESE ISSUES OF
INCARCERATION RECIDIVISM IS AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT WHICH IS WHY
YOU WILL SEE A VARIETY OF
EDUCATION CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS AND SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE?
THERE ARE MANY BARRIERS TO TO
SELL SO REENTRY OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED THAT HAMPER JUSTICE
AND FAIRNESS PROVIDING
APPROPRIATE FUNDING FOR
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION EMPOWERS
INDIVIDUALS THE PUT THEIR LIVES
BACK ON TRACK.
AND BE PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY THE BILL YOU HAVE A
SECOND CHANCE IS FUNDAMENTAL NOT
ONLY TO OUR STATE.
BUT OUR NATION AS A WHOLE IT IS
JUST AND FAIR TO PASS THIS BILL
INTO INSTITUTE -- IN STATE
ENERGY STATE OUR SECOND CHANCE
GOT RENTS WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE
PROFESSOR JAMES HARDEN FROM UC
BERKELEY.
AND I MEAN I ULSTER FROM UC
BERKELEY STUDENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE BOTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
WELCOME TO YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD -- AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
MY NAME IS DAVID HARDING I'M A
PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY AT UC
BERKELEY.
MY RECENT RESEARCH FOCUS ON
PRISONER RE ENTRY AND
REINTEGRATION IN FEBRUARY I
PUBLISHED A BOOK ON THE TOPIC
TITLE ON THE OUTSIDE.
I SPEAK TO YOU TODAY FROM A
REINTEGRATION PERSPECTIVE.
THE QUESTION BEFORE YOU IS WHO
WE WANT COMING HOME FROM PRISON
AND WHAT WE WANT THEM TO DO WHEN
THEY COME HOME.
A WIDELY STATED A WIDELY CITED
STUDY BY THE RAND CORPORATION
FOUND THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATING COLLEGE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS WHILE THEY'RE IN PRISON
OR 48% LESS LIKELY TO RECIDIVIST
HAVE TO THEIR RELEASE.
I ALSO BELIEVE THE TAKING
COLLEGE COURSES IN PRISON WILL
IMPROVE REINTEGRATION EVEN FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T FINISH THE
DEGREE.
MANY WILL SEEK TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION AFTER RELEASE AND
COLLEGES ARE INSTITUTIONS WHOSE
MISSION IS TO HELP PEOPLE TO
IMPROVE THEMSELVES.
BY ALLOWING PEOPLE IN PRISONS
AND JAILS ACCESS CAL GRANTS SB
FIVE SEVENTY FIVE HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE COLLEGE ENROLLMENT IN
PRISON.
THEIR TWO REASONS FOR THIS FIRST
EVEN FOR THOSE WORK CURRENTLY
HAVE ACCESS TO COLLEGE COURSES
THE EXPENSES OF BOOKS AND OTHER
STUDY MATERIALS CAN BE
PROHIBITIVE.
THOSE SERVING TIME IN PRISON
TYPICALLY HAVE TO RELY ON THEIR
FAMILIES TO COVER THOSE COSTS.
SECOND SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN
AFFORD TO PAY TUITION.
THIS IN TURN WILL MAKE IT MORE
COST EFFECTIVE FOR COLLEGES TO
PROVIDE PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA'S
PRISONS.
AND PROGRAMS RUN BY A CREDIT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES WILL PROVIDE
COURSE CRITIC ME PUT TWENTY
DEGREE EVEN AFTER RELEASE.
THAT WILL ENCOURAGE AND ENABLE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS TO ENROLL IN COLLEGE.
ONE OF PEOPLE SERVING TIME IN
PRISON.
WILL NOT PEOPLE SERVING TIME IN
PRISON TAKE ADVANTAGE OF CAL
GRANTS TO MAKE THE PROGRAM
WORTHWHILE I THINK WE'LL SEE THE
ANSWER IS YES.
IN OUR RESEARCH WITH FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WE
FOUND IT ALMOST ALL WERE EAGLES
EAGER FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES WERE
DISAPPOINTED WITH FEW OPTIONS
WHILE THEY WERE IN PRISON.
FURTHERMORE ACCORDING TO
CORRECTIONS TO COLLEGE THERE
OVER FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY TAKING
FACE TO FACE COLLEGE COURSES IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS.
A DRAMATIC INCREASE SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND THERE'S STILL A
LONG WAITING LIST AND MANY
PRISON YARDS WHERE THERE ARE NO
COLLEGE PROGRAMS CURRENTLY IN
PLACE.
WHAT WILL IT COST TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO CUT GRANTS?
FAR LESS THAN WHAT WE'RE LIKELY
TO SAVE FROM LESS IMPRISONMENT
AND LAST RECIDIVISM.
COST OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TO IMPRISON
SOMEONE IN CALIFORNIA.
IF AT LEAST TWO OUT OF EVERY
SIXTEEN PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE THE
FULL FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR CAL
GRANT.
ARE PREVENTED FROM RETURNING TO
PRISON THE STATE WILL SAVE MONEY
MORE THAN THAT.
AND THEY'LL BE -- MORE RESOURCE
RESOURCES WE CAN DEVOTE TO
REHABILITATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PLEASEPROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS A MEAN L. STERN I
SUPPORT SB.
FIVE SEVENTY FIVE AFTER SPENDING
SIX YEARS IN JAIL WHERE -- MY
GED I WAS TRANSFERRED TO VALLEY
STATE PRISON FOR WOMEN IN
CHOWCHILLA CALIFORNIA WHERE I
SPENT AN ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS ON
A COLLEGE WAITING LISTS.
UNFORTUNATELY MY EXPERIENCE IS
NOT UNIQUE I KNOW MANY PEOPLE
WHO ARE EAGER TO OBTAIN A
COLLEGE EDUCATION IN PRISON BUT
BASS ROAD BLOCKS DUE TO
EXTREMELY LONG WAIT LIST.
OR SUFFER FROM INABILITY TO PAY
COLLEGE TUITION PRICES.
THESE POST SECONDARY COURSES
HELP OPEN MY EYES TO A BIGGER
WORLD IN CHALLENGE ME TO WANT A
BETTER LIFE OUTSIDE OF PRISON.
BEFORE MY EDUCATION I WAS
MENTALLY CONFINED TO THE FEW BOX
BOX WHERE I GREW UP.
I PERSEVERED EARNING ASSOCIATES
DEGREE AND OBTAINED ADDITIONAL
CERTIFICATES HOWEVER A LONG FOR
MORE.
I WANTED TO ATTAIN A BACHELOR'S
AND MASTER'S DEGREE BUT COULDN'T
AFFORD THE COURSES REQUIRED TO
EARN CREDITS ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON BARRIERS STUDENTS IN
PRISON FACE.
AFTER MY RELEASE I WAS ACCEPTED
INTO UC BERKELEY WITHIN THE
RELATIVE EASE.
I AM CURRENTLY THE FAMILY UNITY
PROJECT -- COORDINATOR FOR LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS ARE
CHILDREN.
AND A MEMBER OF BERKELEY
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS WERE WE
ADVOCATE FOR CURRENTLY AND
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT POST
SECONDARY COURSES I WAS ABLE TO
ACCESS IN PRISON MY LIFE COULD
VERY WELL BE DIFFERENT THAN I
IS TODAY WHICH IS WHY I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE REMOVE
BARRIERS TO ACCREDITED.
COLLEGE LEVEL COURSES INSIDE BY
MAKING CAL GRANTS ASSESSABLE
PRISONERS.
HAVING SOME FORM OF COLLEGE
LEVEL EDUCATION IS A NEW
REQUIREMENT FOR MOST JOBS SO
WITHOUT IT WE SEND PEOPLE UP TO
FAIL.
THAT'S WHY THAT'S WHY WE NEED
YOU TO UNDERSTAND HOW
TRANSFORMATIVE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION IS TO FOLKS IN PRISON.
THE COMMUNITIES MANY FOLKS
DEVELOP INSIDE THE CLASSROOM I
ONE OF TRONG SUPPORT AND
DETERMINATION THAT LEADS TO A
BETTER FUTURE WITH GREATER
OPPORTUNITIES.
THE MORE PEOPLE WHO HAVE ACCESS
TO THAT EXPERIENCE WHILE IN
PRISON THE BETTER WILL BE FOR
ALL OF US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NEWMAN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE OFTEN WORKS
ON BEHALF OF THE COAST COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BERNIE REINERTSEN SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
KAELIN DEAN WITH BOTH THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AND POLICY LINK IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARK FILL PART WITH POLICY LIKE
IN THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MENDOZA WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IS STRONG
SUPPORT.
A SPONTANEOUS WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LEILA COMBAT AS WITH ROGER
REBOUNDS A CRIMINAL STATE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DANIELLE MEDINA FROM BERKELEY
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AND AS A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED STUDENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL SIR THE HAD A FROM THE
BERKELEY UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MORE BERRY FROM BERKELEY
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CAITLYN VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS HAS THIRTY
AS WE HAVE THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
JEFF BARTOLO WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
ARE EAGER FOR YOU SEE STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
YET ON THIS BILL BUT WE DO
EXPECT TECH SUPPORT POSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS CONCERNS QUESTIONS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED CENTER
BRADFORD WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK THE COALS WAS GIVEN
QUITE CLEARLY ENACT ELOQUENTLY
BY MISS ESZTER ULSTER.
ULSTER SO I APPRECIATE HER BEING
HERE AND I APPRECIATE PROFESSOR
AS WELL SO I ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
PAN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
I TO ME SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK HI WILK AYE
CHIANG BLAST ALL.
GLASS SO I GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL LEAVE THE BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD MAY MEMBERS.
AT C. A SENATOR STERN WHO IS
NEXT ON OUR LIST.
WITH SB.
FOUR SIXTY TWO SENATOR STERN
COME ON UP AND PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THE MANAGER MEMBER [inaudible]
MEMBERS -- PRESENTING TO YOU
TODAY SB.
FOUR SIXTY TWO WHICH IS LOOKING.
TO ADDRESS WHAT WE SEE IS A REAL
GAP IN THE WORK FORCE GOING
FORWARD IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WE DEAL WITH THE
GROWING THREAT OF WILDFIRES IN
THIS STATE -- WE NEED PEOPLE TO
SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS -- THIS
CAN'T ALL BE DISTURBED BY
MACHINE OR MORE AIRPLANES FOR
MORE CAPITAL INVESTMENT IT'S
ABOUT INVESTMENT IN PEOPLE
[inaudible]
AND WORKERS.
AND WORKERS THAT ACTUALLY WILL
BE ABLE TO FEED THEIR FAMILIES
BASED ON MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFER.
SO -- THIS BOTH HAS AN EQUITY
COMPONENT AND A VERY REAL.
ENVIRONMENTAL -- MANDATE BEHIND
IT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES AREN'T LEFT IN A
POSITION WHERE.
WE'RE VULNERABLE TO OUR HOME
BURNING DOWN ANALYZE BEING LOS
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR --
WE'VE GOT SOME OF THE FOREMOST
EXPERTS IN -- SOME OF THE
MANAGEMENT TECHNIQUES THAT ARE
NEEDED -- FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS WORK FOR MANY YEARS
AND WE THINK THERE'S TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND EVEN BEYOND -- THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FRAMEWORK ALL THE WAY UP.
THROUGH APPRENTICESHIPS -- WORKS
IN DIFFERENT TRADES -- WORK IN
THE BUSINESS SECTOR WORK -- IN
CONSERVATION CORES THERE'S A
DIVERSITY OF OF WORK TO BE HAD
HERE -- AND SO WE'RE JUST
LOOKING TO PUT OUR SHOULDERS
THAT WE ONLY GET THE PROCESS
GOING SO WE APPRECIATE IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE NGHT WITNESSES HERE FOR
TODAY FROM YOU SEE EXTENSION.
TWELVE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
THE FIRE RESTORATION GROUP THANK
YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CRAIG THOMAS -- WITH THE FIRE
RESTORATION GROUP.
I HAVE OVER THIRTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING ON FEDERAL
AND STATE FOREST AND FIRE POLICY
IN CALIFORNIA.
I AM ALSO BEGAN MY EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE AND WERE LIVING IN
THE STATE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IN THE HOUSE THAT WAS A
FANTASTIC.
EXPERIENCE FIFTY YEARS AGO AN
AMERICAN OR COLLEGE WHO STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT TO YOUR
CURRICULUM OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
HAVE.
I WON'T -- SHE BY REMINDING WITH
THE ECOLOGICAL AND SOCIAL
CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING CALIFORNIAN TERMS A
WILDFIRE SEVERITY.
AND IT'S IMPACTS TO COMMUNITIES
AND TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND SO THIS BILL SENATOR STERN'S
BILL IS SPECIFICALLY FOCUSING ON
AN EXPLICIT RESTORATION NEED --
THAT IS TREATING COMPONENTS THAT
REALLY DRIVE FIRE BEHAVIOR AND
GETTING A WORK FORCE LINED UP TO
BE ABLE TO WORK IN PERPETUITY.
ONCE WE REACH REACH RESILIENCE
WE NEED TO MAINTAIN AND SERVICES
OF CAREER WORK LIFETIME
PERMANENT WORK THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEEDING CALIFORNIA.
OVER OVER DANCIN FIRE EXCLUDED
FORESTS ARE HOW THE FIRE PRONE
IN THEIR KEY DRIVERS OF FIRE
BEHAVIOR AND THAT THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT FACTOR TO REMEMBER WE
HAVE -- EXPLICIT BEEN VERY
POSITIVE A CURRICULUM COMPONENTS
IN CALIFORNIA IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
RELATED -- TO RELATING TO
FORESTRY AND TO FIGHT WELFARE
TECHNOLOGY IN FIRE FIGHTING.
SO WE HAVE PIECES OF CURRICULUM
WE NEED TO STITCH TOGETHER
SOMETHING THAT'S MORE SPECIFIC
FOR RESTORATION -- SOAP CINDER
STERN'S BILL OF PORCELAIN
RESTORATION WORK FORCE BILL IS A
SELECTIVE EFFORT TO ADD VALUE TO
EXISTING NASSER RESOURCE
PROGRAMS FOUND IN SEVERAL
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
IT IS NOT AN EFFORT TO
COMPLETELY REDO EXISTING COURSE
CURRICULUM OFFERINGS OR TO
CREATE CORRECTLY.
COMPLY COMPLETELY NEW CURRICULA
BUT RATHER TO STITCH TOGETHER.
PORTIONS OF EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND FINE TUNE THEM. TO BUILD A
RESTORATION WORK FORCE PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES FOR FOR PRESS
PROFESSIONAL RESTORATION
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
IN EXISTING COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT NORTH CENTRAL AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
CREATING A MODEL RESTORATION
WORK FORCE CURRICULUM DESIGN IT
THAT IS UNIQUE AND AN IS
CRITICAL.
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT BROAD SCALE
RESTORATION IT WILL PROVIDE A
PERMANENT CAREER PATHWAY TO
ACTIVELY ENGAGE EFFORTS TO
MITIGATE CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
LOSS OF FORCE RESILIENCE STUDENT
UNCHARACTERISTIC MAGNIFIERS.
AND INCREASINGLY THAT ARE
INCREASINGLY COMMON IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE NEED FOR A PERMANENT SKILLED
RESTORATION WORK FORCES NEVER
BRING GREATER AS THERE IS A
CRITICAL THERE IS CRITICAL NEEDS
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING AND YET A
SCARCITY OF COMMUNITY LEVEL
WORKERS WHO KNOWS THE LANDSCAPE
THE VEGETATION THE PARTNERSHIPS
THE AGENCIES.
THE TOOLS THE SCIENCE THE POLICY
IN LAW YOU CAN MANAGE A
PROFESSIONAL NOW TO RESOURCE
BUSINESS IN THE FUTURE PERFECT.
THANK YOU HERE AT THREE MINUTES
SO I'M GOING TO DEFER TO THE
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JANA
VALID QUEBEC I AM THE FORCED
ADVISER AT A LICENSE FORSTER IN
THE COUNTY DIRECTOR WITH THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION.
AND HUMBLED AND DOWN THERE
COUNTIES.
AND IT'S CLEAR TO ALL OF US THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE SOME DRASTIC
CHANGES THE QUESTION IS HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE.
DID YOU OR YOUR FAMILIES HAVE TO
WEAR A MASK THIS YEAR I MEAN WE
ARE UNITED WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE ISSUES OF SMOKE -- WALTER
PROTECTION THE NEED FOR SAFE
COMMUNITIES WERE ALL TIED TO
THIS WE ALL SHARE THE SAME AIR
SHEDS WE ALL SHARE THE SAME
WATERSHEDS.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS A COORDINATED EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING TO DEVELOP A WORK
FORCE IT'S VITAL TO SAVE LIVES
HOMES FORESTS WATERSHEDS FOOD
AND OTHER VITAL RESOURCES.
WITHIN AS BEFORE SIXTY TWO IS A
COMPONENT TO FUND A NETWORK OF
YOU SEE ADVISERS LIKE MYSELF TO
FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON FIRE.
AND I'M HERE TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT WE DO AND
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION BUT NOT TO
ADVOCATE FOR THIS BILL.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE AWARE
BUT YOU SEE COOPER EXTENSION IS
FOUND IN EVERY COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA BOTH RURAL AND URBAN
ALIKE WERE HUNDRED AND SIX YEAR
OLD PARTNERSHIP THAT LINKS
COUNTY GOVERNMENT WITH TRUSTED
SCIENCE BASED ADVISERS THAT HELP
COMMUNITIES BUILD ECOLOGICAL AND
ECONOMIC RESILIENCY.
WITH MORE THAN A THIRD THE STATE
AND PRIVATE OWNERSHIP WHO CAN
BEST REACH THESE COMMUNITIES.
SO AS COOPER DISSENSION AVISORS
WE EVALUATE AND DEVELOP
PRACTICES WE WORK WITH UC
CAMPUSES TO CONDUCT RIGOROUS AND
LOCALLY RELEVANT RESEARCH WE
DISSEMINATE NEW RESEARCH AND
INNOVATION THROUGH TRAINING AND
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS.
AND WE PROVIDE COORDINATION AND
CAPACITY FOR LOCAL AND STATE
LEVEL COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS AND
HELP LANDOWNERS AND AGENCIES
OVERCOME SIGNIFICANT POLICY
BARRIERS WERE THE TRUSTED DEVICE
OF THE PEOPLE TURNED HIM.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WHERE THE
CONTENT DEVELOPERS TO SUPPORT
MANY OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WORK WITH LANDOWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING CAL FIRE
THE FIRE SAFE COUNCILS THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS.
EVEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THROUGH THE NATURIST OR SAYS
CONSERVATION SERVICE AND PRIVATE
CONSULTANTS.
THERE IS PRECEDENT FOR THIS TYPE
OF BILL THERE'S BEEN SIMILAR
SIMILAR LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS WITH
PASSED CONCERNED JUSTICE PEST
MANAGEMENT AND PESTICIDE USE
THAT FUNDED.
A SPECIAL PROGRAM TO THE
UNIVERSITY DEVELOP BOTH RESEARCH
AND EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE IN THIS
DEVELOPED AN INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT APPROACH THAT WAS
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL AND STILL
REMAINS SO TODAY.
I'M HAPPY HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE
IN PUBLIC OUT REACH IN THE
NETWORK AND THE CAPACITIES THAT
WE HAVE TO BRING GREAT RESOURCES
TO CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE SINGLE PICKY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ROBERT SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN WHITE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE FORCE LEVELS OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE CALIFORNIA LICENSE
FORSTER'S SOLUTION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
SEE SEE HEAT IN RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CRISTINA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
SUPPORT.
TASHA NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA -- ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT.
WITH FORSBERG WITH THE TO
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
THE BILL'S REMOVE SENATOR WE
JUDGE CLOSE VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANNA SAY MY
CLOTHES -- VERY OPEN TO WORKING
WITH -- COMMUNICABLE JUSTIN
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN MAKING
SURE THAT THIS IS NOT
DUPLICATIVE THAT WERE WORKING
WITHIN THEIR PLANNING PROCESS IS
WE WANT TO MAKE THIS WORK AND
THERE'S A LOT OF RESOURCES OUT
THERE ARE READY WITHIN THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE SYSTEM BUT
IT'S TIME TO DEAL WITH FIRE.
SO WITH THAT RESPECT FAST DRIVER.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN THE
BILL'S MOVE BY SENATOR PAN MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FIVE S. BEFORE SIXTY TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL WILK I CHIANG
LASSELL WHO DOES SO I GLAZER
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATOR PAN I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WOULD YOU LIKE 2%.
THANK YOU.
SB.
SIX SIXTY BY SENATOR PAN
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATORS.
A CAMPUS COUNSELING SERVICES ARE
NOT MEETING THE GROWING DEMAND
SB SIX SIXTY REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY IN
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO MEET A RATIO OF ONE
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR. TO
EVERY FIFTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS
ENROLLED AT EACH OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE CAMPUSES.
THIS RATIO IS RECOMMENDED BY THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
COUNSELING SERVICES TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES I
WOULD ACTUALLY.
SHOULD VENTURE THAT'S THE OUTER
RANGE THAT THEY RECOMMEND.
SB SIX SIXTY ALSO HOPES TO
REMEDY THE GENERAL LACK OF
CONSISTENT REPORTING THROUGHOUT
EACH SYSTEM BY REQUIRING EACH
CAMPUS TO REPORT THE LEGISLATURE
EVERY THREE YEARS.
THERE IS A GROWING NEED FOR THE
SERVICES AND SB SIX SIXTY
ADDRESSES THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS FACING CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
ARE ALSO GIVING US THE
INFORMATION NEEDED. TO CONTINUE
GIVING THE CARE THAT OUR
STUDENTS DESERVE SB SIX CITY HAS
HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND FROM
OPPOSITION AM PLEASED TO HAVE
WITH ME TODAY DOCTOR IAN WALLACE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY MARITIME ACADEMY.
AND MEDIA AGAIN YES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION -- SPOKE THE ASPEN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THINK CENTER
PAN WELCOME TO YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES PLEASE PROCEED.
THE MORNING CHAIR LEYVA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON DR
IAN WALLACE COUNSELING
PSYCHOLOGISTS FROM CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY MARITIME
ACADEMY.
ON HALF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
THAT STUDENTS ARE SUFFERING
ACADEMICALLY AND PERSONALLY
BECAUSE OF COUNSELING CENTERS
AND SEE IF YOU'RE CHRONICALLY
WOEFULLY UNDERSTAFFED WHICH IS
WHY WE NEED SB.
SIX SIXTY I CAL MARITIME ON THE
ONLY FULL TIME MENTAL COUNSELOR
MY PART TIME CALLING AND I SERVE
ONE THOUSAND FIFTY CADETS AND
OUR SCHEDULES ARE FULL I ARRIVED
EARLY AND STAY LATE MOST DAYS.
YET THE VAST MAJORITY OF MY
COUNSELOR FACULTY COLLEAGUES AT
OTHER SEE ISSUES ARE IN CENTERS
WITH COUNSEL TO STUDENT RATIOS
FAR ABOVE THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF COUNSELING
SERVICES STANDARD OF ONE TO
FIFTEEN HUNDRED RATIO.
WHICH LEAVES AND DROWNING IN
APPOINTMENTS CHARTING AFTER
HOURS WORK HE'S DANGEROUS RATIOS
CHEN COUNSELING CENTERS INTO
CRISIS CENTERS.
HIGH RISK STUDENTS ARE
PRIORITIZE THAT LEADS STUDENTS
HANGING SUCH ON WAIT LIST A
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
IS OFTEN INACCESSIBLE
UNAFFORDABLE I REMEMBER EACH
STUDENT PAYS HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS
IN HEALTH FEES EVERY YEAR. FOR
HEALTH CARE I AGREE WITH DOCTOR
MIMI BOMBERS BACH WHEN SHE
TESTIFIED LAST YEAR THAT IT
FEELS A MORAL AND ETHICAL AND I
KNOW WE CAN DO BETTER.
NATIONALLY DEMAND FOR MENTAL
SERVICES ARE UP 30% INCLUDING
40% ACCOUNT MARITIME THIS YEAR
TO THIS TO MEET THIS DEMAND
WITHOUT EXPANDING ACCESS WE GET
QUOTE GET CREATIVE FOR INSTANCE
I'VE ADDED ADDITIONAL POINTS BY
REDUCING SOME OF THEM.
FROM FORTY FIVE MINUTES TO
THIRTY MINUTES OTHER CENTERS
INSTITUTES STEP CARE WHERE SELF
HELP GROUP COUNSELING COMMITTEE
REFERRALS ARE PRIORITIZE OVER
ONE ON ONE COUNSELING.
AND THESE THINGS ARE
INSUFFICIENT STUDENTS ARE
SUFFERING THEY'RE DROPPING OUT
AND THEY'RE DYING COUNSELING
CENTERS MUST PROVIDE CULTURALLY
COMPANY HEALTH CARE AND SB SIX
SIXTY WILL HELP THIS MEANS
HAVING STAFF TO REFLECT THE
RACIAL AND OTHER DIVERSITIES OF
CSU STUDENTS.
AS WELL AS PROVIDING INCLUSIVE
CARE THAT ADDRESSES THE UNIQUE
SHARED EXPERIENCES OF
COMMUNITIES THAT INCREASINGLY
REPRESENT THE MAJORITY OF THE
CSU STUDENTS MEANING BLACK BROWN
IN NATIVE STUDENTS.
SB SIX SIXTY WILL SUPPORT NEEDED
COUNSELING CENTERS TO HIRE
DIVERSE COUNTING STAFF TO MEET
THESE NEEDS AND LASTLY WE CAN NO
LONGER CONTINUE TO IGNORE THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS WE KNOW BASED ON DANIEL
EISENBERG'S WORK OUT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN.
THAT MENTAL PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
MENTAL SERVICES PAYS FOR ITSELF
IN RETENTION AND TUITION.
AND CONTRIBUTING TO THE
FINANCIAL WELL BEING OF FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M COUNTING ON YOU TO WEAR THE
REAL COST OF IGNORING SUCH AN
OBVIOUS SOLUTION AND SUPPORT
APPROPRIATE AND SAFE CANCER
STUDENTS STAFFING RATIOS AND
DATA COLLECTION EFFORTS.
ASPER SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIXTY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR
LEYVA IN MEMBERS -- I AM NOT MIA
SHE IS OUR PRESIDENT BUT I AM
HER PROFESSIONAL STAFF SO I GET
THE TAKE YOUR PLACE TODAY.
SO MY NAME IS MERRY WASHINGTON
ON THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ASSOCIATE FOR ON CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS.
NEARLY HALF A MILLION CSU
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
WE'RE THANKFUL TO SENATOR PAN AS
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
FOR THE SPONSORS FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
STUDENTS IN THE CAL STATE SYSTEM
HAVE A HOST OF ISSUES THAT THEY
ARE DEALING WITH AS THEY ATTEMPT
TO ATTAIN A DEGREE.
WITH THE COST OF ATTENDANCE
RISING 40%.
OURS OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
HOMELESS 11% ARE FOOD INSECURE
AND THE POLITICAL CLIMATE AND
DISCOURSE ON AND OFF OUR
CAMPUSES.
HAVE CREATED AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH IS
CONSTANTLY BEING CHALLENGED.
IN FACT THE ISSUE OF MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES ON OUR CAMPUS
IS THE TOP PRIORITY FOR OUR
STUDENTS FOR THE SECOND YEAR IN
A ROW.
EACH YEAR CSSA CREATES A POLICY
AGENDA TO GUIDE OUR STUDENTS
WORK FOR THE YEAR THIS YEAR
THOSE THREE PRIORITIES FOR THE
CSU STUDENTS ARE.
STUDENT HEALTH AND SAFETY
AFFORDABILITY AND OVERALL
ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
AND IT'S EASY TO UNDERSTAND WHY
JUST UNDER HALF OF THE TWENTY
THREE CSU CAMPUSES HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELOR TO STUDENT
RATIOS NEAR OR BELOW THE RATIO
OF ONE COUNSELOR TO EVERY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS.
AS PROPOSED IN SB SIX SIXTY THIS
MEANS.
ON THE MAJORITY OF CAMPUSES
STUDENTS ARE REPORTING
SIGNIFICANT WAIT TIMES TO SEE A
COUNSELOR SOMETIMES UP TO A
MONTH.
AND CAPS ON HOW MANY TIMES THEY
CAN SEE A COUNSELOR IN A YEAR
SOMETIMES AS LOW AS FIVE TIMES.
THAT IS WHY PASSING IN FUNDING
SB SIX SIXTY IS SO CRUCIAL WHEN
A STUDENT CAN ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR
NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WAIT
NEARLY A MONTH TO SEE SOMEONE.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES CAN PRESENT
REAL AND IMMEDIATE SAFETY ISSUES
FOR STUDENTS AND THE STUDENTS
AROUND THEM.
ADDITIONALLY ON ALL CAMPUSES
STUDENT FEES ARE BEING USED TO
PAY FOR THESE MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES CURRENTLY.
THIS MEANS THAT THE MOST OBVIOUS
WAY TO EXPAND THESE RESOURCES
WOULD BE -- NOT.
TOO FAT TO INCREASE THOSE
STUDENT FEES BUT THROUGH SB SIX
SIXTY INCREASING -- REALLY
ELIMINATES THAT PROBLEM ALL
TOGETHER AND IT IS WHY AGAIN THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS THE SB
SIX SIXTY WOULD ALLOCATE IS SUCH
A NECESSITY FOR OUR STUDENTS.
THE OVERALL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR STUDENTS IS
CRITICAL AND ENSURING THEIR
SUCCESS.
THANK YOU ALL FOR CONSIDERING
THIS ISSUE AND WE ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT SB SIX SIXTY TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION THANK YOU.
BROWN WRAPPING BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONALIZATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS PART.
LEE INTO THE READ WESTERN
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGE ADMISSION
COUNSELING IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION IN SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON THAT WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION CO SPONSORED THE
BILL JUST WANTED TO MENTION WE
DO HAVE A TWENTY MILLION BUDGET
REQUEST WITH THIS BILL.
JIMMY FROM IN WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
POLICEMEN SUPPORT. SEVEN GOLDMAN
OF THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
DO NOT HAVE A LETTER IN BUT I
LET'S COMMITTEE IS RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEN HERE IN MEMORY BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY.
BILLS BEEN MOVED QUESTIONS
COMMENTS NONE SENATOR PAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I BUT THANK YOU THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
WILK MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AND IN THIRTEEN SB SIX
SIXTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK WILK AYE AYE
CHANGE TO A SONG. TO WRESTLE AYE
GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN HI
CAN I THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES
BUT WE WILL WAIT LEAVE IT OPEN
ARE ON CALL.
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS ALL RIGHT
SENATOR HERTZBERG COME ON DOWN.
SB [inaudible]
SEVEN FORTY THREE REAL FAST.
PROS PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU A MANAGER I'M
SEEKING IN THIS BILL TO DEAL
WITH THAT AMBIGUITY IN CASE LAW.
AS IT RELATES TO DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACTS -- BASICALLY ON ONE
HAND DESIGNED BILL IS AN EX BUT
A DELIVERY ON THE OTHER HAND.
THE CALIFORNIA BAR MIDDLE
QUALITY ACT REQUIRES FULL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT.
THE RISK REAL QUICKLY IS THAT
WHEN THE SCHOOL THIS AWARD THE
CONTRACT FOR DESIGN BUILD THEIR
ENDING TO AN UNCHANGEABLE
AGREEMENT.
THE PROJECT IS APPROVED BY THE
SCHOOL BY THE SCHOOL BOARD
AWARDED THE CONTRACT IN FACT
DOES NOT MEAN APPROVAL.
AND SO THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY
CLARIFIES THAT A SCHOOL DISTRICT
MAY TAKE THE FOLLOWING ACTIONS
TERMINATE THE CONTRACT MODIFIED.
THE DESIGN TO COMPLY WITH SEQUEL
AVOID MITIGATING SIGNIFICANT
CIRCUMSTANCE OR DISAPPROVE THE
PROJECT DESIGN.
SO THE IDEA IS IN THERE SOME
LITIGATION IT OUT IN THE LA U.
S. D. AND THIS IS AN EFFORT TO
TRY TO CLARIFY THAT --
ALTERNATES OVER THE WITNESSES SO
WE CAN CUT TO THE CHASE.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES.
MARCO LETTER ON THE CHIEF OF
FACILITIES FOR LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WE'VE
DONE A LOT OF CONSTRUCTION OF
NEW SCHOOLS BUT WE'RE FOCUSING
ON MODERNIZATION OUR
CONVOLVULACEAE.
ON THERE SOME PEOPLE THAT OPPOSE
DEMOLISHING BUILDINGS AND
THEY'VE USED THE SEQUEL AS A
TOOL TO TRY TO STOP THAT WE HAD
ONE PARTICULAR PROJECT THAT HAD-THEY BEEN.
THEY HAD SUED US AND IF WE TAKE
IN THAT THAT COURSE IN EVEN IF
pTHE PROJECT BY YEAR AND SPENT
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
JUST TO BE ABLE TO GO FOURTEEN
DO WHAT WE BELIEVE WE WERE DOING
WE LIKE SEQUEL WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO CHANGE SEEK FOR WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO ELIMINATE AN AMBIGUITY.
THAT DEFINES HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
THE PROJECT WE CLEARLY HAVE NOT
ENTERED INTO AN OBLIGATION THAT
FORCES US TO DO CONSTRUCTION.
IN OUR CONTRACT ITSELF WE HAVE
PROVISIONS ALLOW US TO TERMINATE
THE CONTRACT NOT PROCEED WITH
CONSTRUCTION WE'VE DONE THAT
BEFORE -- THANK SENATOR BRING
THIS FOR LOOK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NETWORK NEXT WITNESS
MANAGER MEMBERS AS ARE THE OTHER
HALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL FOR
THE REASONS ALREADY STATED ORDER
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NEWMAN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR NANCY TRIED AS IT'S
BEEN US ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING AND SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
I WAS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZERS CENTERS FOR WHICH THAT
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE VERY GOOD BILLS TO MOVE
BY CENTER GLAZER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ADAM
SIXTEEN SB SEVEN FORTY THREE THE
MOTION.
IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WILK WILK I CHIANG
LU ASAL. TO WRESTLE AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
WE BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE DOWN TO OUR LAST
BILL.
AND WE'RE DOING IT ALL CALL FOR
SENATOR ALLEN [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
FOR GLAZER THAT
IS A GREAT IDEA LET'S LOOK CALLS
ON BILLS THANK YOU.
WE WILL START WE WILL START WITH
ITEM.
ONE ITEM ONE SB ONE FIFTY THE
MOTION TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED
HER VOTING I'VE FOUR ZERO CHIANG.
GLAZER PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
BELIEVE THE BILL ON CALL I AM
NUMBER.
TWO ITEM TO SB TO SEVENTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING AYE
THREE ZERO CHIANG.
GLAZER PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE
PAN.
REALLY THAT BILLING CALL AS WELL
ITEM NUMBER THREE PLEASE ITEM
THREE SB FOUR NINETEEN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
FLOOR WITH THE CHAIR HASN'T
VOTED VICE CHAIR VOTING I TWO
ZERO LEYVA BY LEYVA I CHIANG.
GLAZER [inaudible]
MCGUIRE PAN.
I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL AS
WELL FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR ITEM FOUR SB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FOUR
ZERO CHIANG.
GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
CENTER PAN OR VOTING ON EXCUSE
ME SENATOR -- CHIANG WERE VOTING
ON FILE ITEM FOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO VOTE NOW [inaudible]
GOOD.
CHIANG I THINK YOU WILL SOLELY
THAT OPEN FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE ITEM FIVE AS BEFORE SIXTY
TO THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
FIVE ZERO CHANGE.
CHANGE I MCGUIRE.
BELIEVE THAT BILL OPEN AS WELL
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX ITEM SIX AS
BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
OF THE CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED
HER VOTING I TWO ZERO CHANGE.
CHIANG I'D WOULD ASAL.
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER PLEASE ARE
AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL
AS WELL FILE ITEM SEVEN ITEM
SEVEN SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
HASN'T VOTED.
VICE CHAIR VOTING I TWO ZERO
LEYVA HI LEYVA I AM CHANG.
CHANG I AM A GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE PAN PAN I
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL AS
WELL FILE ITEM EIGHT PLEASE ITEM
EIGHT SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I'VE
FIVE ZERO CHIANG.
WE CLING MCGUIRE. FOR THE THAT
OPEN AS WELL FALLON NINE ITEM
NINE SB FIVE EIGHTY TO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FOUR ZERO CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D.
GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
WITH THE BILL ON CALL FILE ITEM
TEN ITEM TEN SB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS AT THE CHAIR
HASN'T VOTED VICE CHAIR VOTING I
TWO ZERO LEYVA.
LEAVE A I CHIANG.
CHIANG MAI GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN PAN I BELIEVE THE
BILL OPEN AS WELL FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
ELEVEN ITEM ELEVEN SB FIVE
NINETY FOR THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
PAN PAN I BELIEVE THE BILL OPEN
FILE ITEM TWELVE PLEASE ITEM
TWELVE SB SIX ONE FOR THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED HUMAN SERVICES
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL RUSSELL AYE
GLAZER [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
PAN.
CAN I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL
CENTER ALLEN WELCOME.
SENATOR ALLEN HAS SB SIX EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE
READY.
IF IT'S A FIVE ENSURING THE
INTENSE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE HEARING.
SO I WANTED TO OBVIOUSLY --
FIRST THING THE COMMITTEE.
AND PART OF THE INTENSITY WOULD
HAVE TO DO WITH A SENATOR
GLAZERS BUILT.
SO THERE WE ARE COULD BUILD A
BUILDING OKAY ALL RIGHT SO I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND IT'S
DETAILED ANALYSIS.
THIS BILL SB SIX EIGHTY SIX
ESTABLISHES A PROGRAM FOR
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS TO
IMPLEMENT COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS THAT IMPROVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CHILDREN.
AND THEIR FAMILIES LIVING IN
SOME CALIFORNIA'S MOST
DISTRESSED NEIGHBORHOODS.
I CHILDREN LIVING IN IN --
NUMBER THESE COMMUNITIES LACK
ACCESS TO ADEQUATE HEALTH SOCIAL
AND ACADEMIC PREPARATION NEEDED
TO ACHIEVE SUCCESS AND IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA 17% OF
CHILDREN LIVING COMMUNITIES OF
CONCENTRATED POVERTY OVER ONE
POINT SIX MILLION CHILDREN.
LIVE IN POVERTY HERE IN THE
STATE.
PLAN TO END THE CYCLE OF POVERTY
FOR THESE CHILDREN THEIR
FAMILIES INNOVATIVE AND
PRACTICAL APPROACHES ARE NEEDED.
TO ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY FACE SO -- THIS IS OF
COURSE A NATIONAL PHENOMENON
UNFORTUNATELY -- AND AND THAT
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION BACK IN
TWENTY TEN ESTABLISH THE
PROMISED NEIGHBORHOOD PROGRAM TO
TRANSFORM SCHOOLS AND
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
ALL THROUGHOUT THE NATION.
OF OF THIS TYPE THROUGH A ROBUST
SYSTEM OF COMMUNITY SUPPORT.
BY WHICH FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
INVOLVED IN THEIR FAMILY IN
THEIR CHILDREN'S ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE AND PROVIDING THEM
WITH QUALITY SOCIAL AND
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES.
SO IN CALIFORNIA -- THERE ARE
FIVE ESTABLISH AN OPERATING
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS SERVING
MORE THAN THIRTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
ANNUALLY.
AND THESE NEIGHBORHOODS ENSURE
THAT ALL CHILDREN GROWING UP I
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
EARLY CHILDHOOD PROGRAMS SCHOOLS
HEALTH SERVICES SOCIAL SERVICES.
RELIABLE SYSTEMS OF FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY SUPPORT THAT WILL
PREPARE THEM TO A TEN X. ON
EDUCATION AND AND SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITION TO COLLEGE AND
CAREERS.
AND TO ENSURE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF OUR PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS
VARIOUS METRICS ARE USED TO
TRACK OUTCOMES INCLUDING
KINDERGARTEN READINESS
PROFICIENCY IN COURT K. THROUGH
TWELVE SUBJECTS FAMILY ECONOMIC
RESILIENCY IN SUPPORT TOWARD THE
CHILD.
IN THE STUDENTS ACCESS TO
HEALTHY LIVING.
RECENT STATS -- INDICATE A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF EFFECTIVE
AND ENCOURAGING OUT COMES FROM A
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD SO FAR HE
WOULD HIGH SCHOOL FOR EXAMPLE
GRADUATION RATES.
HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED
OTHER NOW UP 289% FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN THAT'S A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE EVEN OFF OF
TWENTY ELEVEN ADDITIONALLY IN LA --
PARTICIPATING HIGH SCHOOLS HAVE
MORE THAN DOUBLE THE PERCENTAGE
OF STUDENTS WHO GRADUATE COLLEGE
READY IN THE PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOOD IN SENATOR RISES
DISTRICT.
SO THIS BILL CREATES A PROGRAM
TO BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PART OF EDUCATION TO
AWARD GRANTS TO IMPLEMENT A
PLACE SPACE CONTINUUM OF CREEL
TO COLLEGE AND CAREER SOLUTIONS.
IN TARGETED HEIDI NEIGHBORHOODS
THE PROGRAM INTENDS TO IMPROVE
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT COLLEGE
SUCCESS CAREER READINESS AND
BUILD STRONG FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY SUPPORT.
AND WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES STICKS IN SINGER
ISLAND -- FROM CALIFORNIA
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD NETWORK TO
SEE CAN SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF OF
SB.
SIX EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR ALAN PLEASE PROCEED.
BIOGRAPHY WARNING A CHAIR ELEVEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- I'M
DIXON SINGLE AND PRESENT CEO OF
THE YOUTH POLICY INSTITUTE IN
LOS ANGELES AND LEAD AGENCY FOR
THE LA PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD.
WE'RE HERE TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL -- 686%
AROUND COVERED A LOT OF THE KEY
FACTS I WOULD ADD.
THAT THIS BILL ALSO FULFILLS ONE
OF THE KEY RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE LIFTING CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY TASK
FORCE REPORT WHICH IS I I'M SURE
YOU KNOW CAME OUT IN NOVEMBER.
PROMISED AT A CREATING TWENTY
PROMISED NEIGHBORS ACROSS THE
STATE WAS IDENTIFIED AS THE HE
STRATEGY FOR COORDINATED
SERVICES.
AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY FIVE
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED PROMISED
NEIGHBORS IN CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL WOULD BRING THE TOTAL.
TO TWENTY BY COMPETITIVELY
SELECTING AN ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE MORE THAN
EIGHTY COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT APPLIED FOR THE FEDERAL
DESIGNATION SO IS IS A GROUND
SWELL OF SUPPORT AND INTEREST AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IN BEING DESIGNATED AS A PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD -- THIS IS A MODEL
THAT WORKS WE'VE SEEN
TRANSFORMATIVE RESULTS IN THE
FIVE CALIFORNIA PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOODS JUSTIN LA TO ADD
TO THE COLLEGE READY RATE MORE
THAN DOUBLING UP 271%.
I GRADUATION RIGHT NOW EXCEEDS
THE STATE'S RATE EVEN A MUCH
HIGHER RATES OF POVERTY AND OUR
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS AND MATH
PROFICIENCY ACROSS EIGHTEEN
SCHOOLS.
THE RATE OF GROWTH OF THE LAST
THREE YEARS HAS EXCEEDED THE
STATE'S RATE.
BECAUSE OF THIS IMPACT IN LA
THAT BOTH LOS ENGINE FIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND LA MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI.
SUPPORT THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
Y. P. I. IN THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD NETWORK AND
SUNNY MAKE PEAK WHO HAD TO WALK
OUT EARLY I WANT TO CLOSE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL.
SIXTY SIX THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RICHARD
REID ON THE DIRECTOR MISSION
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD AT THE
MISSION ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY A PROUD CO SPONSOR -- SB --
SIX EIGHT SIX THE MISSION
DISTRICT IS A TRADITIONALLY
WORKING CLASS COMMUNITY IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND OVER THE LAST
DECADE WE'VE SEEN EIGHT THOUSAND
WORKING CLASS LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS.
DISPLACED FROM OUR COMMUNITY.
RENT FOR TWO BEDROOM HAS RISEN
TO FORTY FIVE HUNDRED PER MONTH.
CAUSING FAMILIES TO TRIPLE UP IN
OVERCROWDED APARTMENTS AND SOME
DISPLACED STUDENTS TO COMMUTE
ACROSS THE BAY TO SCHOOL.
THESE AND OTHER CHALLENGES HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO LOW ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE SIX YEARS AGO.
OUR PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD BEGAN
TO WORK WITH MORE THAN TWENTY
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS TWO
STUDENTS FROM CRADLE TO COLLEGE.
AND WORK WITH THEIR FAMILIES AS
WELL.
THE SCALE OF THE SOLUTION BEGAN
TO MATCH THE SCALE OF THE
PROBLEM.
WE WERE TOGETHER AT NINE SCHOOLS
AND THREE PRESCHOOLS REACHING
ALMOST EIGHT THOUSAND CHILDREN.
AND AFTER SIX YEARS WE SAW
GRADUATION RATES INCREASE FROM
63% 288%.
AND PRESCHOOL ASSESSMENT SCORES
JUMPED FROM 24% 288%.
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS
BREAKTHROUGH SILOS AND
COORDINATE SERVICES.
PARTNER SHARE DATA AND WE HOLD
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE TO
IMPROVING RESULTS. TO RIGOROUS
ANALYSIS AND PLANNING.
THIS IS GOOD GOVERNMENT.
THE EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE USE
OF PUBLIC RESOURCES.
TODAY OUR PARTNER NETWORK HAS
MADE FIVE THOUSAND CONNECTIONS
TO SERVICES FOR TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED FAMILIES.
HALF OF THESE.
HALF OF THESE HAVE BEEN FOR
HOUSING AND FINANCIAL ASSET
BUILDING SERVICES.
OTHER REFERRALS INCLUDE MENTAL
HEALTH LEGAL SERVICES AND MORE.
EXPANDING THIS MODEL TO MORE
COMMUNITIES COULD BE
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR CALIFORNIA BY
PREPARING OUR CHILDREN TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR ECONOMY.
AND HELPING FAMILIES MOVE OUT OF
POVERTY.
THERE ARE COMMUNITIES AS NOTED
EARLIER ACROSS THE STATE THAT
HAVE EXPRESSED INTEREST IN THIS
MODEL.
INCLUDING FRESNO SACRAMENTO
OAKLAND MARIN AND MONTEREY.
THE FIVE EXISTING PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS HAVE FORMED THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD
NETWORK.
AND WE STAND READY TO OFFER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ANY NEW
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT COULD
RESULT FROM THIS BILL.
FINALLY WE WERE PLEASED TO HAVE
MORE THAN FIFTY PARENTS AND
THEIR CHILDREN ARE MEAT WITH
YOUR OFFICES YESTERDAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
SIX EIGHT SIX AT THE END OF THE
DAY PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS OF OUR
ABOUT BELIEVING THAT ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN.
CAN SUCCEED NO MATTER WHERE THEY
LIVE NO MATTER WHERE THEY COME
FROM AND IT'S ABOUT US COMING
TOGETHER IS COMMUNITIES. TO HOLD
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE TO THAT
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
ALL.
OF DIRECTOR FOR HAYWARD PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD THE FIRST PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GIANNA THAT ISRAEL COAL HEY WERE
PROMISED NEIGHBORHOOD AND WE DID
BRING TWENTY MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY HERE YESTERDAY --
CHILDREN AND AND PARENTS THAT
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SIX EIGHTY SIX GILLIAN SPENT --
I'M THE CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
AT THE MISSION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE ARE A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE LA CITY MAYOR ON ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT.
WELL GOOD SHAILA WOULD LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND SUPPORT.
JACKIE LONG WITH GRACE AND HELP
HIRING CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
NORMA GARCIA ON BEHALF OF
MISSION ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY PROUD BECAUSE SPONSOR AND
ON BEHALF OF THE MANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE HAD HERE YESTERDAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING HEARING THEN WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE COM
SENATOR DRAW SO.
YES -- I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I'VE WHAT I'VE HEARD
FROM THE ORGANIZATIONS AND IN MY
DISTRICT IS THAT THEY WOULD WANT
IT IF THEY DON'T HAVE IT AND
THEY REALLY.
LOVE IT BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE IT
TIGHT IT MEANS A LOT THAT
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE ST JOHN'S --
AND THE TIE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND CLINIC OF
GOVERNMENTAL IT MONDAY.
THERE REALLY WELL GROUNDED
ORGANIZATION SO THEM SPEAK
ENOUGH FOR YOU MEANS A LOT.
AND WE WANT BOYLE HEIGHTS IN SO
MANY OTHER COMMUNITIES AN ALLEY
TO ALSO PARTICIPATE.
THANK YOU SENATOR RAZA CENTER
GLAZER.
YOU AT YOUR LEYVA GIVEN THAT IT
AUTHORS COMMITMENT TO PLACE ONE
OF THESE IN THE CITY OF CONCORD
AT HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED TO THIS --
SENATORS.
TO ALLEN WHICH I'D CLOSE.
I WOULD CERTAINLY -- THE WILLING
TO CONSIDER -- CONSIDERING.
THE CONSIDERATION OF THAT -- OF
THAT PROPOSAL -- BUT HI BUT YEAH
DO DO DO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM THAT THAT --
HAS NATIONAL LOCATIONS AND A LOT
OF REALLY GOOD WORK IT'S ALREADY
GONE ON ON THE GROUND SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CENTER ALAN CENTER
GLAZER HAS MOVED THE BILL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FOURTEEN SB SIX EIGHTY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK.
CHANG CHANG I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER PLEASE ARE
AYE MCGUIRE PAN [inaudible]
CAN I WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THERE.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO LIVE
CALLS WE LEFT OFF ON FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
THIRTEEN SB SIX SIXTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS OF
THE CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTINGI FIVE ZERO CHANGE.
CHANGE I INQUIRED.
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL OF ALLEN
FOURTEEN WE JUST DID FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN YES.
YOU WERE AN AIBO.
I AM ON WHICH TO FOURTEEN FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN ITEM FIFTEEN SB
SEVEN TWENTY NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED VICE
CHAIR VOTING I TWO ZERO LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE CHANGE CHIANG I'D
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN PAN I
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN PLEASE.
ITEM SIXTEEN SB SEVEN FORTY
THREE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE FLOOR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I'D
CHECK FOUR ZERO CHANG.
CHIANG AYE MCGUIRE.
PAN -- ITEM SIXTEEN SB SEVEN
FORTY CAN I I BELIEVE THAT BILL
ON CALL FILE ITEM.
SEVENTEEN ITEM SEVENTEEN SB
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO.
THREE ONE CHANGE.
CHIANG NO GLAZER [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL
ON CALL AS WELL WHILE WAITING
FOR CENTER MCGUIRE IT MEMBERS
YOU HAVE ANY BILLS THAT YOU HAVE
MISSED.
NUMBER THREE OKAY [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
I THINK CHANGE MISSING ONE OKAY
LET'S GO.
AHEAD ITEM ONE SB ONE FIFTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I'VE
FIVE ZERO CHIANG.
CHING I AM MCGUIRE.
WITH AN ON CALL.
I AM TO ITEM TO SB TO SEVENTEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AT THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I'VE
FOUR ZERO CHANG.
CHIANG AYE MCGUIRE PAN
[inaudible]
PAN I'D.
OKAY ITEM THREE SB FOR NINETEEN
THE MOTION IS TOPASS TO THE
FLOOR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
VICE CHAIR VOTING I THREE ZERO
CHANG.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN
PAN I'D [inaudible]
YOU CAN.
EVERY CONSIDER CHEN YOU'RE GOOD
REQUIRE WELCOME WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU WE ARE GOING TO RUN
THROUGH ALL OF THE BILLS THAT
ARE ON CALL.
AND FEEL FREE TO VOTE AS YOU
WOULD LIKE TO AND DAY.
ITEM ONE SB ONE FIFTY THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I NEVER DEALT.
THE BILL IS OUT ITEM TO SB TO
SEVENTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
SIX ZERO MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL IS ALSO OUT.
ITEM THREE SB FOUR NINETEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FOR
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED
HER VOTING AYE FIVE ZERO GLAZER
MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE.
FILLS OUT.
ITEM FOUR SB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX ZERO
MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE HI BILLS OUT.
ITEM FIVE AS BEFORE SIXTY TO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE
AYE.
THE BILL'S OUT.
ITEM SIX AS BFORE SEVENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE HI THAT
BILLS OUT.
ITEM SEVEN SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE AYE THE
BILLS NOW.
ITEM EIGHT SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
CHIANG MCGUIRE.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NINE SB FIVE EIGHTY TO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM TEN SB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM ELEVEN SB FIVE NINETY FOR
THE MOTION IS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AT THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM TWELVE SB SIX ONE FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED HUMAN
SERVICES WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
VICE CHAIR VOTING I'D FIVE ZERO
GLAZER MCGUIRE.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE THAT BILLS NOW.
ITEM THIRTEEN SB SIX SIXTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE BUT
BILLS OUT.
ITEM FOURTEEN SB SIX EIGHTY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
FIVE ZERO WILK MCGUIRE AYE
MCGUIRE AYE THE BILLS OUT.
ITEM FIFTEEN SB SEVEN TWENTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE
THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM SIXTEEN SB SEVEN FORTY
THREE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE FLOOR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE.
BILLS OUT.
ITEM SEVENTEEN SB SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
THREE TWO GLAZER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE SO MUCH THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
EVERYONE WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED